java has become a mainstay when it comes
to the it industry
java's ability to call hardware and fuse
software code with it is unmatched from
basic machinery like washing machines to
complex systems such as super computers
with one of the lowest attrition rates
java developers have continued to grow
in their fields and will continue to do
so soon making the current window a
right time to learn java hello everyone
and welcome to simply learn's youtube
channel i hope you guys are doing well
today we'll be taking you through the
java basics full course this java for
beginners full course will cover all the
basics of java
in this video you will see how and why
java is used today by the end of this
tutorial you will be able to understand
and deploy basic projects using java but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
technology videos so if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to a youtube channel
and press that bell icon to never miss
any updates from simply
let's go through the agenda for this
full course tutorial
we'll start this video with an
introduction to java followed by
installing java and eclipse on windows
10.
we'll move on and cover basic java
topics like data types tokens and type
conversion in java
once we finish these basic topics we'll
go through our first hello world program
in java
moving ahead we'll cover topics like
arrays and operators in java
we'll then cover topics like conditional
statements in java and loops in java
we'll go through all the different types
of loops present in java
we'll end this video by going through a
mini project wherein we'll create a
calculator with all that we have learned
i hope you guys are ready to learn
something new so without any further
delay let's get started when we talk
about java it is one of the most popular
programming language out there and it
was created way back in 1991 but it was
publicly released only in 1995.
it was developed by one of the famous
developers of our generation who is
james gosling at sun microsystems and
then later java was acquired by oracle
and today oracle owns java java is very
simple and easy to use and we will look
at different aspects of how it is easy
and simple to use it's a write once run
anywhere type of programming language
again we will look at details into into
into this particular concept as well and
when we talk about the usage of java you
can use it to build web applications
mobile applications desktop applications
even command line applications and at
the same time you can also use it to
build complex applications like gaming
applications building microservices or
building distributed computing etc let's
talk about the features of java so one
of the most prominent features of java
is that it's an object oriented
programming language which means that
everything which happens in java happens
around objects
objects enable the execution of the
program objects talk to each other to
exchange data and messages we will look
at a look at the concept of objects in
details in the upcoming lectures
it's a platform independent language
which means that
again going back to the previous point
of write once run anywhere
it basically enables the program to be
run on any platform once compiled so
once you have prepared your program and
you have compiled your program then your
compile program can be run on any
platform it is a strong type checking
language which means that it will force
you to respect the contracts of the
variables to the data types for example
if you have created a collection which
should accept strings then
you can only insert strings in that
collection and it will not allow you to
add an a number or an integer into that
collection so it's a strongly type
checking language so when you run your
program it's a two-step process in java
you compile the program and then you it
then you execute the program which we
also call as interpretation so you have
a java compiler and you have a java
interpreter you first compile your
program and then you run the program
using the help of java interpreter java
also provides automatic garbage
collection it's a really important
feature and if you talk about the
languages prior to java like c or c plus
plus they did not offer this capability
and this capability made java really
popular because it could automatically
find the unused objects and variables
and remove them from the memory to free
up memory space for the program
execution it also provides
multi-threading support which means that
you can build multi-threading
applications like a gaming application
if you take the example of a racing game
for example so this they can be one
thread which is monitoring your
leaderboard score there can be another
thread which is displaying the speed of
the car there can be another thread
which is displaying the graphic there
can be another thread which is
displaying the sound so you see all of
these threads are working parallelly and
java provides the support to create such
applications using the multi-threading
capability it has
java is secure by default because there
are no pointers in java so there are no
possibilities of having any memory leaks
or any reference leaks from the
application again if you take the
example of programming languages like c
or c plus plus you had the concept of
pointers and we we witnessed a lot of a
lot of scenarios and a lot of incidents
where there was a memory leakage
happening in the in the production
application which was which was really a
bad experience for the organizations so
java removed the concept of pointers
totally from its programming language
it's also a very robust language because
it provides a really great exception
handling framework out of the box
which developers can use and implement
to build really resilient applications
so now let us understand how a java
program is run so at first you basically
write your java program and you store
your java program into a dot java file
then you compile your java file with the
help of the java compiler once the
program is compiled the compiler is
going to generate another file which is
a dot class file and this dot class file
is basically the compiled file or also
known as the byte code file so this byte
code or the dot class file code can be
run on any platform be it a linux
platform or a windows platform or a
macos platform or any other platform to
give you some more context the first two
steps where you write your java program
and you compile your java program can be
run on any machine let's take the
example that you ran these two steps on
a windows machine so you ran your you
write your program and you compiled your
program on a windows machine which
generated a dot class file then you
transported this dot class file to a
linux machine and it also worked there
you transported your class file to a mac
os machine and it worked there as well
and that's what brings the platform
independence concept of java that you
can write the program once
on any platform and once you have the
bytecode available then you can run this
program on any other platform of your
choice
okay so that was about how the java
program execution works and how the
platform independence is actually
achieved now let us spend some time to
understand the anatomy of java so once
you download java and install java on
your local machine you will hear the
term jdk actually if you will see that
in the next lecture that when you try to
download the java it will say jdk
download jdk stands for java development
kit so the java development kit is the
installation of the java this is what
you're going to install on your machine
once the jdk or java development kit has
been installed the jdk will provide lot
of other components as well like java
runtime environment or jre java virtual
machine or jvm some class libraries and
some other supporting libraries so let
us understand what happens when your
program is run and how these components
work together to make sure that your
program runs as expected let's start
from here so you install jdk or the java
development kit you write your program
and then you compile your program with
the help of java compiler which is
provided by jdk once the program is
compiled your dot class file will be
generated and then you can
run that dot class file using gre in
fact if you just run your program on
your local machine jre will
automatically kick in and run your dot
class file so the java runtime
environment or jre runs your dot class
file with the help of these three
components let's talk about first
component which is java virtual machine
or jvm so the java virtual machine is
actually the virtual environment inside
which your program runs this is the real
main environment inside your dot class
file is running so when
when this program is running how does it
achieves this environment
for achieving this virtual virtual
machine environment it would need some
runtime libraries and that is provided
by these class libraries for example
there would be a runtime jar or rt.jar
as a shorthand which will be supplied to
the program at the runtime to make sure
that the program runs smoothly then
there are other supporting libraries as
well which your program may be using for
example if this program this dot class
file is let's say a calculator program
then it might be using a square root
function from java.math package so how
do how does the java.math package gets
supplied at runtime it would be supplied
by the other supporting libraries which
are present inside gre so jre will make
sure that your program runs inside the
java virtual machine it gets the
required runtime libraries and it also
gets the libraries which are referred in
your program at runtime and this all
together will make sure that your
program is running so you can see jdk
basically
provides gre automatically and jvm
automatically but you can also install
gre separately if you talk about that
use case where you compile your program
on a windows machine using jdk and then
you exported your dot class file to
another machine and there you just
installed the gre you don't install jdk
there you just installed the runtime
environment and you can run the dot
class file just using the runtime
environment and let's type jdk
java download and hit enter
then you need to find the link which
says oracle.com because like we
discussed in the previous lecture uh
java is owned by oracle so we need to
download it from the official website
only so we can click on this link which
says java se downloads
it will bring us to the downloads page
and we will see different versions of
java you can see the java se15 you can
see java se14 you can also see java se11
and all the previous versions
under another thing which you will
notice that it says lts here which means
long-term support basically long-term
support are the releases for which
oracle is going to provide
long-term security patches and updates
for the non-lts releases java will not
provide long-term support and long-term
patch fixes and long-term security fixes
so it's a good idea to analyze and
evaluate on which version you want to
develop your applications on for this
demo i think it is fine we can go with
the non-lts version and even for your
for your customer facing applications
you can start with a non-lts version and
then upgrade to the latest lts version
whenever that is available so for this
demo we can download java sc15 and you
can also do the same on your machine it
will work exactly the same way as an lts
works
so you can click on the jdk download
option here let's click on that it is
going to bring up the downloads detail
page and you can see uh there are
multiple options given here uh in terms
of what platform you want to install
java on whether it is a linux platform
or it is a mac os machine or it is a
windows platform so like i said in the
beginning of the demo that today we are
going to see how we can install this on
a windows machine so i'm going to
download the windows x64 installer here
if you are working on a linux machine or
a macos machine you can download those
respective installers as well so you can
see the exe here so let's click on this
once we click on this we'll get this
pop-up which will ask us to accept the
oracle technology network license
agreement so we can hit this check box
and click on download jdk 15 and this
shall start the download and you will
see some some exe getting downloaded in
your download box here but as the
download is going to take some time and
uh i'm not going to wait for that and
that's the reason i have already
downloaded the jdk 15 for this
particular demo and that jdk is is
sitting here on my desktop which i've
downloaded prior to this demo so we'll
just run this particular exe which is
exactly the same exe as the one which is
being downloaded so let us double click
on this it will ask you for this pop-up
in some cases so you can just hit yes
basically it is asking whether you trust
this exe or not but as we downloaded
this from official oracle website then
we can trust this particular exe so i
will hit yes
and now the installer is going to unpack
and you might get a screen like this
which will be an installation wizard for
the java sc development kit 15. another
thing which before i proceed i just
wanted to highlight that as well that
you might have noticed about jdk here
it's exactly the same term which we
covered in the last lecture that when
you install java you basically install
the jdk which is the java development
kit and this is also visible here when
it says java sc development kit 15. so
let's hit next then on this particular
page you have the option to change the
installation location of java if you
want to by default it is going to
install in c program files slash java
jdk 15 but if you want to change the
location and you want to install java to
a particular custom location of your
choice that is also possible you just
hit change here and then you can choose
whatever directory or folder or place
you want to install this
java on and you can choose basically
select the appropriate location for this
particular case i don't want to change
that i'm happy with the default location
which is available here so i'm just
going to proceed with this particular
location here so i will just hit next
and then java is going to install and
it's it's very fast installation it
generally takes few seconds as you will
see in this demo basically it is going
to unpack all the all the libraries and
all the runtime libraries and all the
class path libraries which we discussed
in the previous lecture and put all that
into the location which we specified to
install java it will also set up the
rest of the prerequisites which are
required to run java successfully so
looks like the java has been
successfully installed as is visible in
this message and there's also a next
step if you want to
access the tutorials or the api
documentations the developer guides the
release notes etc i don't want to do
that so i will just hit close here and
now if we want to just verify if java is
uh is installed or not then we can
verify that from the command line prompt
let me just exit this and let's go to
the command prompt to verify to see if
java has been successfully installed so
to do that uh we'll we'll just open the
search bar and we'll type cmd it is
going to show us this command prompt
here we'll click on this and it will
open the command prompt for you like it
has open for me and there you just need
to type
java hyphen version and you hit enter if
you get a message like this it means
java has been successfully installed if
you get a message saying that java is
not recognized as a command it means
that java is still not successfully
installed and something has gone wrong
in your installation and in that case
you might want to restart you might want
to go back and reinstall this java exe
again so in this case it looks like it
has been successfully installed and we
can also get some interesting
information from here we can see which
version of java has been installed it
says java version 15. we can also see
that the jre is also installed the java
sc runtime environment or jre is also
installed and we can also see that the
jvm is also installed which is java
hotspot server vm vm means the virtual
machine so if i connect this back to the
previous lecture we can see that
the the java jdk basically installed the
jre as well as the jvm as well and the
complete java package has been
successfully installed now we are ready
to use java
a java program and run java programs on
this machine and at this step i would
like to conclude this lecture in the
next session we will be discussing how
we can install eclipse because that
would be the natural next step for any
java developer that they want to install
java and then they want to install
eclipse and start working open my web
browser and type
eclipse
download
press enter and then you need to find
the link which says
eclipse.org
downloads which is the first link in my
search results you can also see it says
eclipse downloads the eclipse foundation
and eclipse foundation is the one is the
organization which maintains the eclipse
installers so we can click on this
once we click on this we will be
redirected onto the eclipse downloads
page and there again you will see bunch
of options you will see the default
option highlighted which would be the
eclipse installer for uh for jre for mac
os windows and linux and then you have
some other tool platforms option as well
like eclipse g or oreon which you might
want to use for advanced cases but for
running java applications all you need
is an eclipse installer which is coming
from here so based on your machine
eclipse will automatically detect
whether you want a 64-bit installer or a
32-bit installer and you can just click
on this particular link which says
download 64-bit here so i'm just going
to hit download 64-bit it is going to
open this particular screen where based
on your current location eclipse will
suggest the nearest possible
distribution mirror distribution mirror
is basically a server which is present
somewhere
in this world which contains this
eclipse installer exe and eclipse has
created these servers all across the
globes these servers are basically
called the mirrors and based on your
current location which will be deducted
taken taken from your isp from the
internet ip address from which you are
accessing this particular website so
based on your isp location it is going
to suggest you the nearest possible
mirror location so that your download is
the fastest so in my case the nearest
location is netherlands here as you can
see and i get a download option this is
the file name which says eclipse
installer jre windows 64 dot exe and if
you think that this mirror doesn't make
sense just click on this option select
another mirror and then you can choose
another mirror but generally it works
really well it works based on it works
based on your ip location and it's
generally uh the download speed is
pretty good based on the suggested
mirror so i'm not going to change the
mirror location because i think this
works fine for me so and i'm just going
to click on this particular button which
is going to start the download of the
eclipse installer so now i have i have
hit the download button and you can see
right now an exe has been download has
begun to download uh it is going to
again take some time and
i have already downloaded this
particular exe just to save us some time
and i'm going to use that exe to
showcase how we can install it another
thing just wanted to highlight is that
eclipse is an open source organization
it works on donations so if you feel
generous about it and if you feel that
eclipse is doing really great work you
can also donate to it which will show
here so we can move to the next step
which is about installing so you can see
here i have an installer here an exe
file basically which i have
pre-downloaded to showcase this demo i'm
just going to double click on this and
it is going to unpack the installer you
can see this this icon will be presented
to you which says eclipse installer by
oomph
is basically the provider for this
particular installer who manages the
installer and based on your computer's
capacity and speed it is going to take
few seconds and
in the background what it is doing is
basically it is unpacking this installer
and creating all the installation files
which it needs to successfully install
it on your computer once that is done
you will be presented with this kind of
screen and you will see that eclipse
provides multiple different kind of ides
for different set of developer
communities you will see an option which
says eclipse ide for java developers you
will also see eclipse ide for enterprise
java developers you will see the ide for
c plus plus and c developers web and
javascript php eclipse committers who
basically contribute to the eclipse
organization or
rcp rap tester scientific computing
there are tons of ides which eclipse
maintains for our use case throughout
this series i think we will be focusing
on this particular ide which says
eclipse ide for enterprise java
developers you can also use this
particular ide but this is a very bare
bone ide with very limited set of
integrations like it says it includes a
java ide a git client an xml editor a
maven plugin and a gradle plugin but if
you look at the enterprise you will get
more integrations you can use this
particular ide to work on whatever you
work here so these all will work here
but in addition you can also use this
ide to build a web application build a
web service build a jpa application data
tools java server pages faces etc so
this is more more advanced i would say
and we will go with this particular ide
and
you can also choose this id if you want
to but for this demo we are going to
choose this one i will click on this
then it is going to show me which
virtual machine it is going to use so if
you remember in the previous lecture we
installed java 15 it has automatically
detected that location by reading my c
program files folder and it has
automatically taken that if you have
multiple jdk installations on your
machine you can click on this icon and
change a different java virtual machine
i'm going to leave it as is again the
installation folder is also by default
taken to your c users user name slash
eclipse slash the jee
version number and again if you want to
change this you can also change a
different installation folder i'm going
to leave everything as default it will
automatically create a start menu entry
and a desktop shortcut and now i hit
install it might come
ask you for a user agreement so you can
hit accept now and now it has begun the
installation the installation generally
takes a bit of time to complete in some
cases so again it depends upon your in
your computer's capacity and speed
basically if it's a good robust machine
with with good capacity the installation
might be very fast as you can see in my
computer and if you have a computer
which is not very strong on
configurations you can just be patient
and wait for some time and the
installation will be finished once the
installation is finished you will see
this launch option here you will also
have an option to keep an installer if
you want to show the readme file but i
think the the main option here which we
are going to use is the launch option so
if you hit the launch option now the
actual ide is going to start up it's
again going to set up some configuration
files and some bootstrap configuration
files which it needs to and then it will
ask you to choose a workspace again
workspace is up to you where do you
where you want to create your workspace
the workspace is basically the location
where you
will create your projects it will store
those project files and the source code
of those projects so it is up to you
where you want to create it again i'm
going to leave it as default here but if
you want to change it just hit browse
here and choose whatever location you
want to you can see you can choose you
can go to pc and you can choose whatever
location you want to i'm going to leave
it as is and you also have a choice that
you don't want eclipse to ask this every
time so you can check this box and next
time eclipse is not going to ask you to
choose a directory as workspace and
every time you start eclipse it will
automatically go to this particular
directory so you can either check it or
uncheck it based on your convenience and
hit launch once you hit launch it is
going to start the actual ide as a
desktop application and you will get a
nice interface and a welcome screen from
eclipse which will which will basically
show the basic uh overview of the screen
something like this so now you can see
that the eclipse id has started it has a
welcome page which has multiple options
you can check out a project from git you
can import an existing project you can
go to the marketplace create a java web
project or whatever or you can just
close this you have a nice navigation
project
project explorer bar here so all the
projects which you're going to create
will be listed here there are also some
quick shortcuts here for creating
different kind of projects
and if you don't want to use that just
go to file new and choose a kind of
project you want to create whether it is
a maven project or enterprise
application project or dynamic web
project or just a project if you just
hit just a project you can choose a
basic java project to start with click
next give a project name let's call it
test demo
you can choose an execution environment
here that the jre and currently this
particular ide has support up to 14 but
i think this is going to work fine we
don't need to worry about it we can also
use a project specific jre like in this
case java 15 which is the current
installation so i can use this option
because i want to use java 15
environment because i have java 15
installed so you can basically choose
whatever option you want to choose it
gives you flexibility in terms of
choosing the gre whether you want to
choose an external gre whether you want
to choose a project specific jre or you
want to use the default gre jdk
installation so you can use this option
as well if you want to project layout is
create either you want to create
separate folders for source and classes
or you want to create the use the
project folder again this is these are
just basic configurations which you can
play around with if you want to i'm just
going to leave it as is and hit next and
then it is going to just give me a
review screen here if i want to change
anything i can otherwise i can just hit
finish
i can create a module name here if i
want to but i don't want to create it so
just hit on don't create and open the
java perspective
and that's it you have a java project
here where you can create your java
files under this src and you can start
executing those files we will look out
on those details in the upcoming
lectures but for this lecture i think
this is what we wanted to achieve we
wanted to show how we can install
eclipse and how we can create a very
sample
java cli project and just type java
primitive data types
and if you hit enter the first link
which you will be given is this
particular link and this is the same
link which i have opened so let's learn
about the data types now so java has
these primitive data types which you can
see here some of them store numbers some
of them store boolean values and some of
them store characters so the data types
which store numbers are byte short int
long float and double
these six
data types basically are used to store
any kind of numeric value let's
understand these a bit more byte is the
shortest possible data type value which
you can use in java to store numbers you
can only store numbers within the range
of minus 128 to plus 127. so you can see
the range is very small and java has
created this variable for use cases
where you want to store numbers which
have very small value in this range why
do we provide these kind of options just
to save memory because the smaller data
type will require less memory to be used
in the java program similarly the next
bigger data type is short which is a bit
bigger than byte and the range of this
particular data type where
variables will range from minus 3 to 6 7
8 to plus 3 to 7 6 7. so that is the
range for this particular variable and
you can see that it has a it has a very
big range as compared to the byte data
type so if you want to store very uh
values which lie in this range you can
use short the next one is inch data type
you can use this one to store even
larger values which range from minus 2
raised to power 31 to plus 2 raised to
power 31 minus 1. the next one is long
which is even bigger than int and it can
be used to store the values within the
range of minus 2 raised to the power 63
to plus 2 raised to power 63 minus 1. so
as you can see as we go from top to
bottom from byte to long the size of the
value which can be stored using this
data type increases and that's how you
will basically take a decision of
whether you want to use byte or you want
to use short or int or long based on
what size of the value that variable is
going to contain then the next ones are
float and double these two have been
created for the use cases whether where
you want to store the values numeric
values which have decimals which are
precision values i should also mention
that byte short int and long are only
used for storing
absolute numbers which do not have any
decimal representation even if you try
to store a decimal value in these
variables they will automatically be
trimmed the decimal values will
automatically be removed and you will
only be
shown the absolute values
and in case of float and double they can
maintain those precision and decimal
values so we use float for the use cases
where you want to store decimal
representations of the values and you
can see that the float value can store a
smaller precision value but double can
store even a bigger precision value so
if you have really big precision values
to be maintained very big decimal values
to be maintained you should use double
and the float is used for
storing a bit smaller size of the
precision values i mean it's range of
values basically beyond the scope of
this discussion if you want to read more
about this you can go to this particular
links which will explain this in detail
but the basic idea is that float is good
for storing two precision values and if
you want to go beyond that you want to
use double in some cases some people
also use float to store even beyond two
values as well so it completely depends
the main the decision factor is how long
the value you are going to store in the
decimal and that will take the decide
whether you want to use float or double
the next one is boolean which is used
for storing the boolean values boolean
values can be either true or false so
there are only two possible values and
then we have care which is used for
storing characters
it is
using 16 bit to store the value and this
is a very popular java question for
beginner level programmers that why does
it store uh you need 16 bit to store the
character it's because it stores a
unicode representation unicode
representation is a representation which
can be accepted across platforms across
the world in different character
encodings
so let's move on to eclipse now where i
have prepared a very short and simple
demo i'm just creating a variable for
each data type and i'm printing them you
also see some things here like
these keywords and don't worry about
these keywords i will cover these
keywords in detail in the upcoming
lectures you also see this and you can
just for now you can remember that
system.out.println is used for printing
anything in java anything you want to
print on the console you would be using
system.out.println
what is system what is out and what is
println again we will cover these in the
uh upcoming lectures
for now i'm just creating a bunch of
data types here variables here basically
i'm creating a cad type variable a byte
type variable a short type variable an
in-type variable a float type variable a
double and a boolean the way you create
variables is basically you put the data
type name you put the variable name
which can be anything you put an equal
sign and you put the value actual value
which this variable is going to store
and i've done the similar thing for all
of these
variables java wants semicolons to be
there when you write your statements so
please remember that your statements
always end with semicolons so i've
declared all of these variables here a
byte a short and int flow double and
boolean and then i'm printing all of
them basically here i'm printing the cad
variable here i'm printing the byte
variable here i am printing the short
and so on so forth so how do we actually
run this application or this program you
just double click on this or right click
on this you go to this run as option you
see this run as java application option
so you can hit this option it will run
the application and it will present all
the output here in the console tab let
me just bring this up so you can see all
the variables have been printed here and
this is coming from these print
statements like i said this is used
system.out.println is used to basically
print anything and i've used that to
print all the variables here first i'm
printing the car variable
whose value is
a then i'm using the byte variable which
is denoted by b and whose value is 2 so
you can see the value is 2 here then i'm
printing the third variable which is c
which is a short type variable which has
a value 22 you can see short and this is
coming here the next print statement is
int so you can see int here with the
value 45 and this value is coming from
here then we have float
we can see the float value being printed
here and you can see the float value
declared here you also see an f here and
this is the standard naming convention
with java proposes that whenever you
declare float and double you end them
with f or d based on whether it is float
or it is double then you see the double
value which is having which is having a
bigger precision than float so i've
printed the double value using
this particular print statement which is
printed here and then we have the
boolean value which is stored as g
and the value of g is true and the same
value is printed here so whatever i
write here basically is printed here
this is just a placeholder and this is
the actual value so you can see that we
are able to use all the variables here
all the primitive variables basically
which range from byte character byte
short int float double and boolean and
that's it for this session in the next
session we will be discussing about the
non-primitive data types in java string
data type and array data type and like i
said for classes we have a dedicated
lecture upcoming so don't worry about
that and again for this particular case
as well i have already prepared a demo
for this and we'll basically do some
look at some hands-on examples to see
how do we create these variables what is
what does these variables mean and the
first non-primitive data type we are
going to talk about is string and before
i go on further i should also mention
that it's very debatable in the java
community to call string as a
non-primitive data type and actually
technically speaking string is a special
data type it neither fully lies in the
primitive category nor it fully lies in
the non-primitive categories i'm
covering this as as a non-primitive data
type because it's a bit inclined towards
the non-primitive category why do we do
this is because java does provide native
support for string handling in the jdk
and that's the reason some of the
developers feel that string is a
primitive data type which is primitively
supported by java but at the same time
string is so customizable and it's so
special in nature it's the way it stores
the value the way it provides the
operations and handlings it's so
different than primitive data types that
it cannot fully be put in the same
bucket as the primitive data types so
that's why i said it's it's a special
data type a bit inclined towards the
non-primitive category so what is string
basically we covered about the cad data
type in the previous lecture and in cap
data type you can only store a single
character right but if you want to store
a complete name of somebody then it's a
list of character it's basically lot of
characters together then in that case
you would need a data type to store that
continuous sequence of characters and
that's what string does string can store
a continuous sequence of characters
technically string is basically a
character array you can call string as a
character array and don't worry if you
don't understand about the word array i
will explain that in the same lecture so
basically it stores the continuous
sequence of characters that's how that's
how we define string and you see this
string this is basically the keyword the
data type basically in java so whenever
you want to create a string you need to
write string with s capital you need to
give a name to the string this can be
anything and then you can provide the
value which is which this particular
string is going to contain so you can
see this is a continuous sequence of
characters t e s t are the four
characters which this string is going to
contain and after that again i am
printing this particular value and like
i said don't worry about this we'll
cover this when we'll when we'll write
our first program in java so this is
just to print the string value i'm just
putting a string placeholder here and
then i'm actually printing the printing
the values of the string variable now
string can be created in multiple ways
in java this is one way of creating it
there is another way of creating a
string variable which is this one which
says
again the string data type some variable
name
a keyword called new again don't worry
about what is this new keyword we'll
cover this when we'll talk about running
our first program in java and writing
the first program from scratch then we
against a string and then we provide the
value so if i compare this line number
four to line number seven you can see
the difference is that i'm still storing
the same value test but the difference
is that here there is no new string
keyword but here we have this new string
keyword so what is the difference the
difference is this that in this case
in this particular case string is going
to
reuse the same object multiple times but
in this case every time you call this it
is going to create a new object again
what is object it's just you can think
of it as for now you can think of it as
a memory block we'll again cover objects
in details but these are two different
ways in which you can create string this
is generally the most popular way of
doing it because this is memory
efficient because you can reuse the same
variable again and again so i'm creating
the string variable here and creating
another string variable str1 here and
printing both of them
then i've created this strange looking
thing here which is basically an array
array like i said is also an a
non-primitive data type in java and
array can store
a continuous sequence
of anything that anything can be a
number
that anything can be characters that
anything can be or a floating number as
well so basic idea is that if you want
to store a collection or a sequence of
multiple multiple of values how do you
do that you do that with the help of
arrays array is a data structure a
non-primitive data structure in java
which can store lot of values of similar
type we also call it as homogeneous data
structure which because it can only
store same data type values or
homogeneous data type values so the the
biggest way to identify array is this
square bracket whenever you see this
square bracket in java it means it's an
it's an array variable so here i am
creating an integer array variable with
the name arr this is the name of this
particular array it is only going to
store integer values because of
specified int and the moment i provide
the square brackets it's mean it means
that it is an array so you can declare
an array like this and then you need to
assign a size to the array size is
basically denoting how many values
this data structure is going to store so
i'm saying new again it's a keyword and
i'm saying that okay create a
memory block for storing two integers so
this particular array arr can store at
max two values two values at continuous
locations the next thing about array is
that it stores the value in a zero index
based location so like i said it can
store two values so the first location
will always be array of zero and this is
how you specify the location for index
of the element which is going to be
stored so at the zeroth location of this
array i'm storing zero the first
location of the array i'm storing one
and this is just to show an error
scenario but i will just comment this
for now you can just put double slashes
and comment any line so i'm just storing
filling up this array for two values and
the two values location would be zero
index and first index these are just
continuous memory locations and we
denote those memory locations as 0 and 1
array indexes always start with 0 and
i'm just putting some values here you
can put any values and then i'm printing
the whole array and i'm also printing
the first value of the array and we'll
see how this pans out and we'll also see
how we can change this so now we are
going to run this application so i'll
just go to run as and click on run as
java application and once i hit that i
get this output here so let's understand
this output the first one is i'm just
printing the string which has the value
test and you can see it has printed here
it is coming from this line then the
next line which is printed is line
number eight where i'm saying another
string str1 and str1 also had the same
value so you can see another string has
the same value and then
i have printed the array here the
complete array and you see this strange
value here it also tells us that if you
want to print the array then you cannot
just put the variable name and print it
the reason is because this is a
non-primitive data type and once you do
this it is basically printing the memory
footprint of this array the whole memory
location where this array is stored
that's why you see this strange looking
number which is the memory hash code and
if you want to print any particular
value or any particular element inside
this array then you can do that by
providing the index location of that
element so here i've said that print the
zeroth location element of the array the
zeroth location array element of the
array was zero so you can see the value
zero here let me put some other value
just to just for fun and show you how
this works so just change the values and
now let's see
what do we get for array 0 you can see
now i get value 3 because now that at
the 0th location the 3 value is being
stored and that is what is being printed
here we can also print the first value
i'll just go run as java application you
can see now the array of first index is
being stored which is basically
technically the second element of the
array but because array always works on
a 0 index based value format that's why
when we say array 1 the second element
is printed when i say array 0 the first
element is printed so always remember
that array is a 0 index based collection
or data structure basically what happens
if i do this
now there is no third element in this
array because the array has the size
only of two elements and when i say air
are of 2 which means i am trying to
print the third element in this array
which does not exist so let's see what
happens in that case
i get an exception exception is
basically an error i get an error saying
that index 2 is out of bounds for length
2 it means that the array length was
actually 2 and index 2 does not exist
remember it's saying index 2 not the
element 2. index 2 doesn't exist because
only index 0 and index 1 exist this
makes two elements and the actual size
is also two it does not have capacity to
store third element it does not have
third element location anywhere that's
why it complains that you are trying to
print a non-existing value so this is
where i would like to conclude my
lecture about the non-primitive data
types so we covered about string we
covered arrays and like i said we'll
cover classes in the upcoming lecture as
well uh in the next session we are going
to talk about tokens in java these
tokens are broadly divided into five
different categories these categories
are keywords
identifiers constants
special symbols and operators so let's
talk about each of them one by one so
when we talk about keywords these are
the words which are reserved by java and
they have a predefined meaning you might
have already seen some of these reserved
keywords for example we have used int
when we were working on the primitive
data type lecture we have seen this as
well though we haven't actually
found out the meaning of this but we
will find out the meaning of this in the
coming lectures so don't worry about
that we have seen boolean as a as a data
type again we have seen byte so these
boolean byte int
class care catch super switch
synchronized all the all the keywords
which you see here these keywords have a
predefined meaning in java and you use
these keywords so that you want to take
an action an expected action by java for
example if you call something as int
then you want java to treat it as int
int will only have a single meaning in
java and there is no other meaning of
int in a java program so that's the
intent with the keywords these are
reserved words which have a predefined
meaning and we will cover these keywords
at length during this whole course
the next token is identifier and
identifier is is nothing but just a
variable name technically and we have
already covered this this kind of
identifier when we were showing the
demonstrations for primitive data types
and non-primitive data types etc it's
basically anything which you declare as
a variable is an identifier and when you
declare the variable name again java
puts some sort of restrictions as to
what you can or cannot do
when you work with java and you declare
the variable names for example these
variable names cannot start with numbers
so you cannot have a variable name which
starts with any number you cannot have a
variable name which contains spaces in
between them you either have to fill
those uh if there's a if there's a
variable name which you think has two
parts for example student name then you
need to write it as student underscore
name so that you can create the variable
name with the same impact and still does
not contain space so spaces will not be
allowed when you create the variable
names similarly you cannot have plus
hyphen and ampersand in the variable
names as well these are the restrictions
with java puts on the identifier tokens
whenever you create identifiers the next
one is constants and we will cover these
constants in detail in the coming
lectures as well but to give you an idea
of what constants are so constants are
basically exactly what they sound like
they are the identifiers which you have
declared in your program whose value
cannot be changed once defined so if you
write something as
final
int i equal to 5 then this value is
fixed you cannot change the value of i
again in the program java will not allow
you to change the value of i again
because i has now become a constant
because you have put a final keyword in
front of it and again final is a keyword
you see final is a keyword basically so
you so these constants are treated
specially by java that java will make
sure that their values will never change
during the course of the execution of
the program these can come really handy
when you have situations where you do
not want the certain variables values to
be to be modified for example if you
have an application where you are
counting the number of applicants and if
you have declared the number of
applicants as final then every time you
call the application you can do a plus
one to the previous value the value will
not be reinitiated so it is very useful
concept and and it can be very handy in
programs where you don't want to change
the values the next is special symbols
these special symbols are the symbols
which again have a predefined meaning in
java we have already seen this square
bracket symbol in our previous lecture
when we were creating arrays so whenever
you use these square brackets then java
would understand that you are trying to
either access or create an array or you
are trying to access or create a list
etc so this is predefined you cannot use
this anywhere else or with any other
meaning similarly when we talk about
these braces these standard brackets are
standard braces these again have a
predefined meaning in java generally
whenever you will write functions and
methods in java you will use these
brackets to define the parameters of the
function now you cannot use these
brackets in any other meaning in java
java will not allow you to use this
anywhere else apart from using it in
method parameters similarly the next one
is the curly braces and the curly braces
are used to define a code block in java
you might have already noticed that when
we were looking at the previous demos
you could see some curly braces then
some code and then the and then the
curly brushes would end for example if i
show you here it just it's just a sample
example and let me open the example
which we covered in the last lecture so
you can see this curly brace here and
this curly brace ends here right so this
defines a code block in java any code
block which you want java to understand
will always be starting with a curly
braces and ending with a curly brace i
remember i talked about the standard
braces you can see these are the
standard braces opening and ending and
this is where we are defining this
particular methods arguments now what is
method what is argument don't worry
about that we will cover in detail but
just an introductory concept whenever
you are trying to define a method and
you want to pass any argument to the
method we use these
brackets to do that okay
similarly this is semicolon is used to
close any java statement so you will see
this semicolon here every java statement
has to have a semicolon as ending
otherwise java will complain that it is
a syntactical error so it is part of the
syntax you need to put the semicolon and
semicolon has only one meaning in java
which is that your statement is actually
ending
then we have star and star is used for
multiplication and then we have equality
which is used for assigning any values
and again assigning any values is
everywhere you are seeing this equality
sign everywhere so these are all tokens
basically the last type of token we have
is operators and we will cover these
operators in the upcoming lectures in
detail with the examples but these
operators are basically some special
symbols like for arithmetic it would be
plus minus multiplication divide for
comparison it will be uh greater than
less than for logical it would be
ampersand and and pipe operators bitwise
again will have some bitwise operation
operators they so they so these are
basically different categories of
operators and under each category of
operators there are certain symbols like
for arithmetic we have plus minus we
have come for comparison we have greater
than less than etc so these again
symbols are also reserved by java under
the operators tokens category you cannot
use these in any other meaning or in any
other way and like like i said we will
look at a detailed example of this as
well in the coming lectures so this was
a quick overview of what are different
types of tokens in java so we have
keywords we have identifiers constants
special symbols and operators
so this is it this is all what i wanted
to cover in today's lecture and in the
next session we will be looking at data
type conversions so when we talk about
data type conversion the whole idea is
to basically answer the question that
whether i can convert a int data type
variable into a long data type variable
or a long data type variable to a float
data type variable and also vice versa
can i go back can i convert a float
variable into a long variable or an int
variable and vice versa so this lecture
is about answering all of those
questions and we will basically look at
some examples to understand how the
conversion works but let me just explain
the basic principle the basic principle
is that smaller box can fit into larger
box but if you have to fit a larger box
into a smaller box you need to do
something else so
what do we mean by smaller box and
larger box here the smaller box is a
variable or a data type which has a
smaller range if you remember we talked
about the range of short byte int etc
and we could see that as we go from
short to byte to int to long to float to
double the ranges were increasing right
so we will follow the same kind of
analogy that if we have to store a
smaller range variable into a larger
range variable java will automatically
do that but if i have to store a larger
range variable into a smaller range
variable then i have to sacrifice some
quality of the value and we will look at
the examples of that as well so let's
first
look at the example where we can store
our smaller range variable into a larger
range variable we call this as implicit
data type conversion so
here you can see i have declared an int
variable with the value 100 and i am
printing the int variable then i have
declared a long variable and what i'm
doing that i'm assigning the value of
int a
to the long variable b so i'm not
assigning a new value to this long
variable but rather i'm just passing on
the existing integer value into a
variable of type long similarly after
that i am taking the value of this
variable of long type and storing this
value into a float type so you can see
int is basically smaller than long and
long has a smaller range than float so
i'm just storing a smaller range
variable into a larger range and then a
larger range variable into the largest
range and then i'm printing all the
variables values to see if this actually
is working can long automatically store
the value of a and can float
automatically store the value of b here
i am just printing the variables and
again using the concept of the previous
lecture this is just to print the values
and i will cover this in detail in the
next lectures of how this works but here
you can understand that we can use
system.out.println
to basically print the values and here
i'm just printing a string and then the
value then again the string and the
value and here also the string and the
value so this is what is happening in
this program and again don't worry about
these details i will cover about what
these concepts are in the upcoming
lectures so let's run this and see if
the data type conversion actually works
so i will just right click and do run as
and go to java application and if i
click on this i get this output so the
first output is pretty straightforward i
am just printing the int variable as is
so this works then i am storing the int
into a long and printing the long
representation of a which is b basically
and this also works without any errors
or any warnings by java similarly when i
talk about storing the long variable
into a float variable c this also works
but here you see an additional decimal
precision here because as we remember
from the previous sessions float is used
to store values which have decimals or
which have positions so it will
automatically convert your absolute
number into a number which has decimals
whenever you try to cast this into float
casting is also a word which is used
some people call it as implicit data
type conversion some people call it as
implicit data type casting so if you
hear the word data type casting or
implicit data type casting you can think
that it is exactly the same concept as
data type conversion so this is about
implicit data type conversion now let's
look at an example of explicit data type
conversion how does that work so using
the same analogy of the boxes now i will
try to store a larger ranging value
variable into a smaller range variable
and see how that looks like so i will
start with the largest which is which is
double variable so i have quickly a
double variable and as we know that
double is a is a variable which is used
to store decimal values so i'm storing
this value here and then i'm just
printing the double representation as is
without any changes
then i'm trying to store this variable's
value into a float variable so i'm
trying to go to a smaller box now i'm
trying to grow from double to float and
if you remember i told you that if you
have to do that it will not work out of
the box but you have to do a bit uh
something special as well and this is
the special part this is called type
casting type casting is basically a way
to tell java to explicitly cast this
variable's value into this data types
variables value and you always need to
do this whenever there is no implicit
casting happening if you are trying to
store a larger value variable into a
smaller value variable you have to do
this otherwise java will complain you
will get a compilation error so that's
what i'm doing i'm telling java to store
the value of a as a float and store the
value in f and this is where i'm telling
to store the value as float so you just
put brackets and you define float and
then i'm printing the float
representation similarly in the next one
i am trying to store the value of this
double variable into a long so you can
see now i'm trying to go even
from our precision data type to a
non-precision data type because long
does not understand decimal values so
i'm trying to store a variable which has
decimal values into a variable data type
which does not understand decimal values
and we will see how the output looks
like but here also you need to do the
explicit casting explicitly you need to
tell which data type this a needs to be
converted into that's what i do here and
then i print the long variable here and
then next i will again go down further
and i will try to store a larger long
variable type into a smaller int
variable type so again i'm trying to
store the value of b
into a smaller data type which is
integer and i'm naming the variable as c
here again i have to do this explicit
casting i'm telling that telling java to
explicitly cast the value of b which is
a long data type variable into an
integer c which is an int data type
variable and then i'm just printing the
value so this is what is happening in
this program that from double to float
to long to int now let's run this
program and see what happens so i will
right click and go to run as and choose
the java application option and this is
the output i get first of all for the
double representation the value gets
printed 0 is ignored then in the float
it works fine as well without any
precision loss because float can also
print values up to one to two decimal
points without any problems even beyond
that actually so it works fine then when
we talk about the long representation we
are trying to convert a double variable
into a long variable and we see that the
precision the decimal values are lost
this is expected because long does not
understand decimal values that's why
anything after the decimal or in fact
the whole decimal portion is gone when
you're trying to store double or float
into some absolute data type variables
like tint or long and then in in
representation since you already have
this long this long can easily be casted
to int by just providing this explicit
casting and the int representation also
prints 50. so we started from this value
and we ended up with these values when
we tried to store them as long or inked
so this is all i wanted to cover in
today's lecture so we covered basically
about the data type conversion or data
type casting concepts how does implicit
data type casting works and how does
explicit data type casting works and as
we know the concept the basic concept is
that the
the value can easily be casted from a
smaller range to a larger range without
any changes or without any extra code
but when you have to go from a larger
value to a smaller value you have to
provide these casting instructions to
java to successfully cast those
variables so that's all for today's
session and in the next session we will
be looking at how we can write the first
hello world program in java and there we
will actually cover all the all these
things which which i have been saying
that we will cover so we will cover all
these ways of how we can write the first
hello world program in java so as we
have already covered how you can install
eclipse and how you can create a sample
java project in eclipse if you haven't
seen that please go back to my previous
videos where you can actually see that
and once you have created your java
project so your java project might look
like something like this you will have
an src folder here so and under the src
folder uh you see some some namespaces
sort of things created here right we
call these as packages and in java you
can think of package as something which
can group multiple related artifacts
together this is simply a grouping
mechanism i can say it's a way to put
all the related artifacts to a
particular business problem into a
certain place for example if you are
working in an ecommerce application so
you have you might have created multiple
java files for
let's say for checkout and then some
more java files for the
filters flow i would say then some other
java files for designing the
advertisements so you have multiple java
files and these java files now below
belong to these three different domains
so you want to group them together for
easy accessibility for referencing each
other
files with the within the code so if you
want to achieve that kind of flexibility
you would group the checkout code files
into a single package you can name it as
checkout package then you can similarly
do the same thing for the advertisement
package and for the filters package so
similarly uh i have created some
packages here which you can see you see
a package here which says i o github
vkeshpande hello world and how do you
create a package you just right click on
this
so you go to the src and you right click
to go to new and here you will see this
option which says package so you can
just click on this and write anything
which you want as the package name let's
call it as test package
it says invalid because the package is a
keyword so it is not allowing me to put
package here but let's call it test
package one and you can just click
finish and you will see a test package
popping up here then you can right click
on this again go to new and then you can
create a java class now what is a java
class a class is basically a blueprint
for an object it's basically the
specifications of an object like i
covered in the very first lecture
everything in java is an object or most
of the things in java are object i would
say so
object is basically an instance of the
class so let's say you create a class
for if i take the same example of
e-commerce you create a class for
writing the business logic of checkout
and then you create instance of this
particular class to work for a
particular customer order so class is
basically a blueprint it's the
specification it's the skeleton of the
object so once you click on this you can
create a class now eclipse is a pretty
smart ide it will provide you with bunch
of options on how you actually can
create a class what and it will also
provide use with some sensible defaults
for example it will automatically select
a source folder in your project which
you have created it will automatically
select a package in fact the currently
selected package and if you want to
change the package just hit browse and
choose any other package which you want
to choose so your your class file will
be created in that package then you can
provide a name to the class so let's
call it as
test
hello
world and you can see i have followed a
sort of a naming convention here the
first character i've kept it as capital
and then any other new world which is
coming in my class file name is also
capitalized so java
would expect you and it would encourage
you to follow this naming convention
that whenever you are creating a class
always start with a capital letter then
small letters and every new word you are
writing can start with a capital letter
again java will not throw an error if
you don't do this uh h capital or w
capital but it's a good practice the
next thing is the modifier we are going
to cover the modifiers in details in the
in the upcoming lectures but for now you
can understand that anything which is
marked as public is accessible to every
other java class in this whole project
that's the basic meaning of making a
class as public public as the name
suggests itself it means it's visible to
everyone you can select the super class
and again we'll talk about this super
class later but this is the java lang
object is the super class of all the
classes which are created in java again
interfaces again an advanced concept and
there are some other interesting uh
defaults it provides for for example if
you want to create a main method now
what is the main method we'll just cover
it in a while so i will not do that i
will leave everything as default and i
will click on finish so i have this new
file coming up here and you can see it
has automatically picked up the package
which i selected and it has also written
public class
test hello world with a starting and
ending curly braces in the previous
lecture we covered about this curly
braces that all the code block have to
be in the curly braces whenever you
write a java class the very first
statement java would expect to have in
the class is package name so make sure
that you have package as a keyword and
then the actual package name as the
package name for that particular class
you can see the package follows a dot
convention and it always ends with a
semicolon like all the java statements
and with semicolon so that would be the
first thing which you will write in your
class second thing is the access
modifier of the class like i said you
want this class to be accessible to
every other file in this project then
you can mark this class as public the
next thing is the class keyword you need
to write this particular keyword as is
otherwise your class will not be
detected so you write this as class then
you write test hello world or whatever
name you want to write but make sure
that whatever public class name you
provide here that name should match with
the file name these two things should
match the file name and the class name
if they don't match you would experience
weird behaviors as the class will not be
compiled the class might not be able to
run etc so always make sure that
whatever file name you provide you
always have a class with that name in
your file so my class structure is is
ready but there's nothing here in this
class in fact you cannot you cannot even
execute this class because for executing
the class for executing any class in
java any class at all in java you would
need a main method in java main method
is the entry point method of the java
whenever you are trying to run any
application be it a very small or very
large java application you would always
and always need a main method in the in
the class in the project somewhere and
you need to tell the java
runtime to execute that class and then
the class will have a main method and
the your program will start executing so
always have a main method otherwise your
program will not execute and how do you
write the main method so you first write
public
then you write static
then you write void
and then you write me and then you
provide
a parameter to this method as this now
let's understand what did i actually
write here first keyword is public
because this method has to be public
because like i said java runtime needs
to be able to access this method so the
similar concept which applied on the
class is applied on this method as well
that the entry point method has to be
public otherwise java will not be able
to find this method so you need to make
this method exactly as public the next
keyword is static you again need to
write this keyword as is and the reason
we write static here is because we
we want to run this particular class
without creating an object of the class
static is again a keyword which we will
cover in the upcoming lectures but for
now you can understand that whenever you
want to access
something within the class without
creating an object then you need to
create it as static the next is void
void is basically the return type of
this method the method name is main and
it has to be main it cannot be main one
or main two otherwise if you do that
java will not be able to run your
program because it will expect you to
write this particular method exactly as
what i have written here no changes at
all should be there if you make any
changes java program will not run
because it will not be able to find the
entry point method which is the main
method so public static void main
remember that you need to have this in
your program so white is the return type
which means that this particular program
it will not return anything back to the
runtime because a method can have this
capability to either return something or
not return something for example a
method which can
add to numbers will return the result of
addition right so we return the result
return is the word here in this case
this method is not expected to return
anything because there is nobody
consuming it right java runtime will not
do anything with the with the return
value of this particular method that's
why java will force you to write void
here and main is the exact method name
which you need to use java will expect
you to supply a string array argument if
we covered arrays in bit detail in the
in the in the previous lectures and we
will cover arrays in actually in the
next lecture in very detail but you can
as we discuss that array is basically a
sequence of characters or words or
integers or anything right so in this
case this is basically the mandatory
parameter which you need to write as is
this parameter name can be anything
obviously it can be a rg args or
whatever you want to write it as but the
basic fundamental is that java will
basically supply all the command line
arguments using this particular string
array that's why you need to provide
this then let's write something in the
program because this is a hello world
program so i will just write
system
dot out dot print ln and i'll type a
string here which says hello
world and a semicolon so again i have
been saying that i will explain this and
now i will explain this why do we need
this and what does this mean so as i
have told earlier that whenever you want
to print something on the console in a
java program you need to write
system.out.println
now system here if you just go if you
just hover over it eclipse will show
what it is so system is basically a
class which contains several useful
class fields and methods it cannot be
instantiated means you cannot create an
object of it and it provides many
facilities like
standard input standard output and error
output exactly what we want to focus
here because we want to
use system class to print something on
the standard output the standard output
in this case is the console so if you
want to input something or you want to
output something or you want to output
an error then you need to use system
class and all of these standard input
standard output and error are streams
and that's what comes to the next word
what is this out how it is a stream to
print standard output similarly we have
system.err which is for printing the
error output streams similarly we have
system dot in for taking its standard
input streams so system dot in
system.out system.err these all are
these in out and err are streams and
then print ln is the actual method let's
hover over that let's first see out here
so you can see this is a stream object
which is used to print anything which is
ready to accept output data basically
and then we go to the println method and
it says print a string and then
terminate the line so like i mentioned
earlier as well this whole syntax is
used to print and actually this is the
core method this is the real method
which prints something on the console so
system class uses the output stream to
print something on the console using the
help of println method there is also a
print method so there are two methods
one is print and one is println the
difference is that in case of print
method the print method will not provide
you or terminate on a next line but in
system.out.println
the ln means line here it will print
something and it will bring the cursor
to the next line if you do not use this
and if you again use another print
statement then both of the statements
will be printed on the same line i will
show that as well but uh and then we
provide any random string here which we
want to print so you right click on this
particular program you go to run as and
you run as java application and you want
to save this so you can say always save
resources before launching and you see
the output here so this is how you can
run your first java program now let's
also see the difference between
system.out.println and system.out.print
so i will just copy this here and i'll
say hello world
1 let's say and this time i will not use
system.out.println
but i will use system.out.print
just put a space here so that it's
visible so if i use print how does that
look like i go to run and i go to run as
java application so now you see both of
the outputs are printed on the same line
there is no this output hasn't gone to
the next line and now if i run the same
program with
system.out.println methods now both of
these outputs will be divided on two
lines the first output then a line break
the hello world one goes to the next
line in the previous run the hello world
one was printing right next to it on the
same line so that is the difference so
this is how you can build your very
first program the hello world program in
java and this is where i would like to
end this particular session as well in
the next session we will be discussing
about arrays in java so as i described
earlier that array is basically a
container which can store values or a
sequence of values or sequence of
numbers or sequence of characters into
itself we can think of it as a box which
can store all the values in a continuous
fashion as you can see here this is just
a pictorial representation and this is
coming from the official java docs and
you can see that we if we create an
array of size 10 then we have these 10
blocks created here you can see 1 to 10
so the whole length of boxes the number
of boxes here are 10 but the way arrays
are designed is that the index index is
basically used to access the element in
this particular box the index of the
boxes start from zero so it goes from
zero to nine so remember the array
length is ten it
the array can contain ten elements but
the index of the array starts with zero
and will always
end at length minus one which is ten
minus one in this case which comes as
nine so it will always be length minus
one it will always the index will always
start from zero and go till length minus
one length can be anything in this case
the length is 10 so the index ends at 9.
if the length was 20 the last index will
be 19 but in total you have these 10
memory locations we also call them as
continuous memory locations because they
are continuously
placed and array basically blocks 10
memory locations and creates a container
over it so this is how an array
basically looks like inside the memory
and
whenever you want to access the elements
of the array you will say array of 0 or
array of 1 or array of 2 you basically
need to specify the index to access the
element at index for example if you want
to access the element which is sitting
in this box you need to say array of
index 8 and we'll see how we can do that
but this is the basic understand
understanding an idea of the concept of
arrays so let's try to understand this
with the help of an example i will
switch back to eclipse ide and i've
created a very simple program here to
demonstrate the functionality of arrays
here so
we already covered in the previous
lecture of what is package and what is
public and what is class how do we give
the class name and what is the meaning
of this particular method so i'm not
going to cover that again we'll start
directly from here so here the first
thing which i'm doing is i'm declaring
an array of integer this is a variable
name the identifier basically it can be
anything and this is the data type it's
an integer array and as we as we covered
this as well that whenever you put
square bracket in front of a data type
it becomes an array data type so this is
an integer array representation now we
just declared an array but we still
haven't allocated a size to it so you
can do that with this particular uh
syntax so you can put the variable name
of the array and say new int and put the
right size here this size can be
anything and once you do this now array
will actually allocate those memory
boxes which we covered here but the
moment you do new int 10 this box these
boxes continuous boxes will be placed in
the memory and the memory is allocated
to this array we call this memory
allocation this is how you allocate
memory to the array so we allocated
memory to this array for storing 10
integers the next thing is now we can
start storing elements in those boxes so
like i said that the array index always
starts with 0 so if you have to store
the first element you actually have to
store it at index 0 location so you give
the array name you provide these square
brackets and you put the index value
within the square brackets that is how
you basically point to a particular
element inside the array so we say an
array of 0 and we put the value 100 then
we initialize the second element which
will be index 1 then will be the third
element which will be index 2 4th
element index 3 5th element index 4 6th
element index 5 and so on until we store
till the last element so this is the
tenth element which is accessible as
index nine and the value is uh thousand
basically so from 100 to thousand we
stored 10 values in this array and we
store them by accessing the index and
this is actually the only way you can
store values in the array by pointing to
the indexes so we go from 0 to 9 and we
stored all the values 0 being the first
element and array of 9 being the last
and the tenth element remember the
length minus one concept okay so now we
will try to print all the elements one
by one that's pretty much what we are
doing now so as we covered in the
previous lecture that we use
system.out.print
to print anything and we understood the
whole meaning of this so i'm not going
to repeat that now
we want to print the first element the
first element is sitting at index 0 and
we can access that element with this
syntax by providing the variable name
and the actual index value so i'm just
writing a random string here which says
element at index 0 and then i'm putting
this plus here and putting the variable
name this plus is basically used to
concatenate the output of a static
string with a random variable or
basically you can print anything uh with
using plus plus is used for
concatenation so i'm just trying to
print this whole value but here this is
a string value which is a static string
and then i have a value coming from the
array so whenever you have to print some
value from a particular data type or
variable or collection then you can use
this plus syntax to concatenate a string
static string with your actual value so
that's what i've done here by saying
plus and array 0 and similarly for index
1 i'm printing the
the first index then for 2 3 so far and
so on so forth till the index nine so
basically i'm just printing the all the
values of the array starting from index
0 to index 9 so that's all which which
is written in this program now let's try
to run this program so i will right
click go to run as and go to java
application and hit on this and now if i
just expand this console you can see all
the system.out.println statements have
been executed and they printed this so
this is the static screen a string part
in fact including the colon this is the
static string part element in index 0
printing exactly as is and then
dynamically the
zeroth index element of an array is
printed here similarly we have printed
the index one location element index two
location element index three location
element and so on so forth till the
index nine location element so in total
these are the ten elements but the index
always works from zero to length minus
one in this case it will be going from
zero to nine so this is basically all
which i wanted to cover in this lecture
the whole idea was to give you more
understanding of arrays and remember
this is just an integer array you can
similarly create a character array you
can also create a string array for for
you as well so it it's completely uh
it's completely related to the data type
you are using if you create a care array
then you can only store characters into
it if you create a string array then you
can only store strings into it and now
you can probably relate back to this
particular thing which i explained in
the previous lecture that we create this
string array for the reason that when
you run this particular program and if
you want to provide any command line
values command line arguments to the
program those arguments will
automatically be stored in this args and
then you can access this as args of 0 or
gsf1 etc in your program that's the
whole concept so this is the basically
the deep dive one array which i wanted
to cover and in the next session we are
going to cover about operators in java
when we talk about operators in java
there are multiple types of operators
like assignment operators arithmetic
operators unary operators then we have
conditional operators and logical
operators and we also have bitwise
operators and we will cover all of these
operators one by one we will understand
what how what these operators are and
how they work and we will also look at a
demonstration of it so let's get started
the first operators we are going to
discuss is about arithmetic operators
and assignment operators and we will
also see if we can cover unary operators
so
when we talk about assignment operators
i have again opened the official java
docs here if we understand assignment
operators we have been using this
operators all the while in all of the
demos so far and the basic idea is very
simple whenever you assign a value to a
variable you use the assignment operator
which is nothing but the equal sign we
have already covered this in multiple
demos so i will not cover this as part
of the demo but what i am going to cover
in detail is about these arithmetic
operators so arithmetic operators are
basically used to perform any kind of
arithmetic operation on a java program
it can be an addition operation it can
be a subtraction operation it can be a
multiplication operation a division
operation or an operation by which you
can find the remainder of the division
so we will look at each of these
with an example and as you can see the
symbols are expectedly what you
generally use in mathematics so
you see the the plus sign here which is
for addition you see the minus sign
which is for subtraction you see the
star sign which is for multiplication
you see the slash sign which is for
division and you see the percentage sign
which is for finding the remainder of
our division so let's see an example of
each of these and how we can use them in
a java program so for the arithmetic
operations i have prepared a
demonstration of it in the eclipse ide
again i'm using the same java project
which i've shown you we created in our
previous lectures so i will for all the
demonstrations i will just continue on
the same project so
again the way to create a class remains
the same exactly the same as how i
covered in the previous lecture in the
hello world program where we created a
class so here also i created a class i
named the class as arithmetic demo and i
have a public static void main method
inside this particular class and i have
basically tried to demonstrate each of
the operation so let's start with the
addition operation first
so i create an integer variable here
named as result and then i try to use
the addition operator to make this
variable store the result of this
addition so it's a simple one plus two
you can also create two different
variables for one and two let's say x
equal to one and y equal to two and you
can also do int result equal to x plus y
it will have the same effect but just
for simplicity i have put the literal
numbers here so result is storing the
the expression value of 1 plus 2 and
then i'm printing this value here you
can see i'm printing the result variable
here with using
system.out.println then i'm storing this
result into a variable into a new
variable original result with using the
assignment operator and then i'm trying
to subtract something from it so now i'm
saying result equal to result minus 1 it
means whatever the current value of
result is subtract minus 1 from that
value so the value was 3 here and here 3
minus 1 becomes 2 so the new value of
result becomes 2 the original result
still holds 3 because it is storing the
old value the new value of result has
now become 2 so i'm printing the
original result and
then what i'm doing that i'm again
assigning the new result which is 2 to
the original result so now original
result and result both are at 2 then i
move ahead and i try to demonstrate the
multiplication operation so i take the
same variable result and i say multiply
it by 2 so whatever the value of result
was which at this place should be 2
multiply that value by 2. so 2 into 2
the new value of result should become 4
after this multiplication operation and
again i'm assigning the value of
original result to this particular
variable and then i'm showcasing the
fourth mathematical arithmetic operation
which is division so you can see result
by two here so basically on whatever the
current value of result is i'm dividing
that value by 2 so 4 divided by 2 should
become 2 so again the new value of the
result variable should become 2
then i'm printing the value and again
storing the value
back into the original result then the
next operation is again an addition
operation where i whatever the value of
result is at this particular point which
is 2
add 8 to that particular value so the
new result value becomes 10 and then i
am printing that particular value again
assigning the original result to the
result and then to showcase the
remainder operation
i am doing result
we call this particular operator as mod
or modulus so result modulus 7 so the
current value here is
in this case would be 10 so i'm saying
10 mod 7 so 10 mod 7 would become 3
because if we divide 10 by 7 the
remainder should be 3 and this modulus
operator is used to calculate the
remainder of a division operation so
that 3 will be stored in this result
variable and then we print that
particular variable so that is what i'm
doing if i take you back up there i'll
just minimize this window and this
window as well so if i take you back to
the starting
i'm doing an addition first here at line
seven then i am doing a subtraction at
line 12
then i'm doing a multiplication at line
17
and a division at line 22
and then again an addition at line 27
and then a modulus at line 32 and i'm
printing the respective values
so let us run this program and see what
results do we get so i right click i go
to run as i go to java application there
is also a shortcut for it if you want to
use the shortcut you can use that so i
click on this and the output is is
displayed here so you can see let me
bring this output back to its original
position yeah i just dragged it here to
the top to the bottom so if we start
from the top and see what all results
did we get printed so line 9 says 1 plus
2 equal to the value of result so 1 plus
2 equal to at this particular point the
result value was 3 because 1 plus 2
equal to 3 moving on the next variable
here is minus so the current value was 3
we said 3 minus 1 which becomes 2 and we
store the value of result or 3 into this
result variable and we print that value
at line 14. so original result plus
original result is 3
then a string here minus 1 equal to so
this is just a string
and then the actual current result value
which is 2. so far so good we move ahead
and then at line 19 we are multiplying
the current value of result by 2 and
again displaying the original result and
the current value so
2 is the original result here because
here 3 minus 1 had become 2 so original
result value was 2 multiply that by 2
becomes 4
then moving on to the line 24 2 by 4 by
2 should become 2 so 4 by 2 equals 2 the
current value of result then again
moving on to the next variable
at line 29 now the result value should
become 10 because 2 plus 8 is 10 and
again we are printing the original
result and then the current result value
so the original result was 2 then we
added 8 to it and the new result value
had become 10 which is coming from this
particular variable
moving on to line 34 we are again
printing the original result which was
10 here
and then we are saying this particular
string which is modulus 7 and the
current value of result is coming from
this expression which is 10 modulus 7
and like i said modulus or mod operation
is basically used to calculate the
remainder of a division operation which
so 10 divided by 7 remainder is 3 so
that becomes 3 and that's why you see
the value 3 so this is a demonstration
to show you how we can use the addition
subtraction division and modulus
operators which are all the arithmetic
operators
and i think this is where we should stop
this lecture so in the next session we
will be discussing about the other
operator types which are unary operators
and we will also discuss some other
interesting operators which are
popularly used in java so when we talk
about unary operators technically they
are also arithmetic operators but they
provide agreement operator and logical
complement operator so when we talk
about the unary plus operator basically
it is used to indicate a positive value
so whatever value you are having it will
just make that number as positive number
you might be wondering that this plus
has an addition meaning as well right
which we saw in the previous example yes
that's correct but when we use that
addition symbol we use that between two
variables but when we talk about unary
operators they are used with a single
variable that is why the name unary
because they are used with a single
variable they require only one operand
so
unary plus basically makes any number
positive usually minus negates an
expression and makes that number
negative
increment operator increments the value
by plus 1
decrement operator decreases the value
by -1 and logical complement operator
involves the value of the expression
from true to false or false to true
let's understand this with the help of
an example so i have created a class
here called unary demo and i have a
static void main method here and i have
created a variable called result and the
first example is about using unity plus
so i'm creating a variable called as
result assigning the value as 1 and just
putting one plus in front of it which
makes this as positive value though we
can argue that this also has the same
effect as this and yes that is true but
in case if this value was written as
something like minus 1 instead of plus
then
we could basically make that number
positive
by just putting plus in front of it so
that's basically the power of unary
operators and that's how you generally
use unary operators so i just put it
back to plus one the next example is
about decrement operators so the current
value of result was 1 because we did
this now we are saying result minus
minus which means whatever the value of
result is
just decremented by 1. so the current
value was 1 so now the new value of
result after this evaluation becomes 0
so at line 14 we print the current value
of result which is 0. moving on at line
16 we are using the increment plus plus
operator here which means whatever the
current value of result is just
increment it by 1. so the current value
of result was 0 till this line so it
becomes 1 because this means increment
by 1 so line 18 will basically print
that value 1 and then at line 20 i'm
using the unary minus operator which
means whatever the value of result is
just negate it just put a negative in
front of it just make that number
negative
so if i just say minus result the
current value of result was 1 so it
became minus 1 and then to showcase the
negation operation i created a boolean
variable
named it as success assigned the value
of this variable as false and printed
the value of success variable as is
first
and then printed the value of success
with a negation in front of it with an
exclamation mark which will basically
flip the value or invert the value of a
boolean variable so if this was false
line 28 should print true if this was
true
line 28 should print false in this case
this is false so the line 28 should
print true
so let's right click on this and run
this program and see if we get the
expected output and yes we see the
output here so let's try to interpret
the output now the line 10 should print
1
yes then line 14 should print 0 we see 0
here
line 18 should print 1 because we use
the increment plus plus so 0 plus 1
became 1 then we use the unary minus
operator so the value should become -1
yes we see minus 1 here and then for
boolean variable we should see first or
false
because the value is printed as is and
then we are printing a negated value so
we should flip the value from false to
true and yes it is printing the value as
true so this was about unary operators
now when we talk about this increment
and decrement operators what if i put
this particular value in front of result
what effect is that going to happen
let's analyze that part as well so for
that i have prepared a separate demo
again i've created a class called pre
post demo and it has a public static
void main method i'm declaring an
integer variable i with the value as 3
so the i becomes 3 here and then i'm
saying i plus plus
as we have already seen in the unary
demo example this should increment the
value of 3 to 4 so it will print 4
expected right then
at line number 9 i am putting this plus
plus in front of i
now what will happen
now
it is going to increment the value of i
and then basically assigning the value
of i
so the whole difference between i plus
plus and plus plus i is that
in this case
the value of i is assigned first and
increment later
in this case the value of i is
incremented first and assigned later so
here the value from 4 becomes 5
so at line 11 if you see if we print i
it will print 5 because we have we are
saying that first increment the value
and then update the value of i so
increment happens on i equal to 4 and i
becomes 5.
at line number 13 it becomes more
interesting because here inside the
system.out.println statement itself i'm
saying plus plus i now what will happen
like i explained
first the value will be incremented
and then the value will be assigned so
before printing the value is getting
incremented so the value from 5 becomes
6 here at line 13 but if i try to do
this
now i am saying
first assign the value of i
and then increment it so i at this line
is still 6
because i has already been assigned 6
and as the post increment says
if you put this plus plus after the
variable it means that you are first
assigning the value and then
incrementing the value so anything which
happens after line 15
the value of i will become 7 but at line
15 the value of i is still 6 because we
are using a post increment operator so
the value is still assigned to i as is
and then incremented and when we do
system.out.println the assigned value is
printed not the incremented value
so like i said after line 15 the value
of i will become incremented by 1 and it
will become 7. so hope you understood
this example or and the difference
between the pre increment and post
increment remember the thumb rule that
if we put plus plus before a variable
like at line number 9 the value will be
incremented first and then assigned so
at line 13
the updated value will be printed
because the first we are doing the
increment and then we are printing the
value for assigning the value similarly
at line 15 we are first printing the
value and then incrementing the value so
when the value is printed at line 15 the
old value of i will be printed but after
line 15 the new value of i will be
accessible to the program so let's right
click on this and run this program
and now if we see the values we assigned
i to 3 we did a post increment here so i
becomes 4 we print the value of i so
here the value of i is 4 we see 4 here
then at line line
9 we are saying plus plus i
so 4 plus 1 becomes 5 though this is a
pre-increment but since we are not
printing this plus plus i as is it does
not have any any change so the value of
4 becomes 5 at line 11 we print 5 then
at line 13 we are saying plus plus i
which means increment the value of i
first and then assign it so the value of
5 becomes 6 and then i gets updated and
printed similarly at line 15 first the
value of i is assigned and printed and
then incremented so at line 15 the value
is still 6
you see this 6 here and then the value
is incremented so after line 15 the
value becomes 7 so that's how we are
basically using the unary operators and
this is where i would like to end this
particular session in the next session
we will be discussing about other type
of operators which are comparison
operators and logical operators etc when
we talk about relational operators they
are sometimes also called comparison
operators and the basic idea behind
using these operators is to compare
things or compare the values of
variables or compare the objects in java
so in java if you need to compare
anything for example if you want to
compare if something is less than the
other thing or something is greater than
the other thing or something is equal to
the other thing then you need to use the
comparison operators which are provided
by java here you can see i have opened
the official java docs and you can see a
bunch of comparison or relational
operators both of the terms are used
interchangeably some people call them
comparison operators and some people
call them relational operators
so you can see if i want to compare if
an object or a value is equal to another
value then i use the double equal sign
if i want to compare for non-equality i
will use exclamation with an equal to
which means not equal to if i want to do
a greater than comparison then i will
use the mathematics greater than symbol
if i want to do the greater than equal
to or less than or less than equal to
they again follow the same kind of
terminology as we see in mathematics so
this is all we have in terms of the
relational operators so let's understand
the usage of these operators with the
help of some examples so as you can see
i have created a class here which is
called comparison operator there is a
public static void main method inside
this class
and this method has two variables of
integer type called value one and value
two value one has the value one and
value two has the value two and then i
am trying to compare the value 1 and
value 2 variables using the different
relational operators we just covered for
doing that i need to use a conditional
operator as well we will be covering
conditional operators in much much
detail in the upcoming lectures but for
now you can understand that when we talk
about conditional operators we talk
about if an else statement so if is
again a keyword in java which can be
used to compare things and the syntax is
very straightforward you write the if
keyword and then you write the actual
comparison syntax or the actual
comparison expression so in the first
example we can see that i am writing a
condition which says evaluate if value 1
is equal to value 2. i should put a
curly braces around here you can see
there are no curly braces here but that
is for a case when you have only one
statement under it but again i will
cover this in detail and i don't want to
confuse the audience here so i will just
put curly braces around all of these if
statements so that it becomes easy to
interpret what is actually going on in
these code blocks as we know that these
curly braces are used to define a code
block so the first if block says compare
if the value 1 is equal to the value 2.
if yes then this condition will become 2
and the control of the program will go
at line number 10. if this condition is
not true then the control will not go
inside 10 because this condition is
false so it will never go to line 10 and
it will move to line 11 or 12 instead
similarly the next condition is we are
comparing the value 1 is not equal to
value 2. so this condition will only be
true if these two values are not equal
or unequal and if that is the case then
line 14 will execute it otherwise line
14 will not be executed similarly in
this condition i am saying compare if
value 1 is greater than value 2 or not
so if the actual value holded by value 1
variable is greater than the value 2
variable then this condition will become
true and the line 18 will be executed
otherwise it will be skipped then
similarly at line 20 i am doing the
reverse i am comparing if value 1 is
less than equal less than value 2. if
that is the case then line 22 will be
executed otherwise it will be skipped
and at last i am also showcasing an
example of less than equal to operator
that you put less than and equal to
together and again you compare the two
variables similarly you can also use
greater than equal to variable
comparison operator as well in this
example so we have an example of
equality not equal to greater than less
than and less than equal to let's run
this example to understand so for
running the example i will just right
click here go to run as and click on
java application and we can see the
output here so as the value 1 holds the
value 1 and value 2 variable holds the
value 2 obviously 1 is not equal to 2 so
the first condition is not going to be
evaluated to true so line 10 will never
be executed because 1 is not equal to 2
similarly if i talk about the next
condition which was if value 1 is not
equal to value 2 then execute statement
14 and yes 1 is not equal to 2 that's
why we see this particular
system.out.println here you see this
printed moving on is value 1 greater
than value 2 so is 1 greater than 2 no
it's not so line 18 will never be
executed then the next one is is value 1
less than value 2 so yes 1 is less than
2 so line 22 will be executed and we see
the line 22 output here
system.out.printer and output moving on
is 1 less than equal to 2 yes 1 is less
than equal to 2 so this particular
condition is also true and line 26 will
be executed and that's why we see this
here and that's all so we can see that
we are able to use these comparison or
relational operators to evaluate
different conditions and we write those
conditions using the if block and again
if you do not understand the if block
fully don't worry we will be covering
the if blocks in detail but the focus
here is in using the operators the not
equal to operators the greater than
equal to operators less than equal to
operators etc so i hope these operators
give you a better understanding of how
to use them now moving on to the next
section of this
comparison operators sometimes we also
use some logical terms to do the
comparison for example if i just move
down here and i show you these
conditions here we call them conditional
operators conditional operators are used
to evaluate the conditions like and or
or and we use them in two two ways
either we can use it as ampersand or
double ampersand or we can use them as
pipe or double pipes so the idea is
basically to evaluate if one condition
is true and other condition is also true
or one condition is true or other
condition is true so whenever you want
to combine two conditions together
that's where you're going to use these
logical operators or conditional
operators you can also use the simple
english keywords like and or or or you
can use the logical representation of
these keywords for example ampersand
ampersand or double ampersand is
equivalent to and similarly double pipe
is equivalent to or so we can use these
as well interchangeably you can use
either of these operator representations
to run our conditional check in
composition meaning you can compare two
conditions saying okay if one is true
and second is true or one is true or
second is true so the whole focus is
here in and and or comparisons so let's
switch back to the ide and let's look at
an example of this to understand this in
detail so i will again take the similar
kind of example again i have created two
variables here value one and value two
value one has value as one and second
variable value 2 has value as 2 and then
i'm writing two conditions this time in
the same if block you can see i am
writing first condition saying is value
1 equal to equal to 1 and is value 2
also equal to equal to 2 so this whole
if condition is only going to be true
only if both of the conditions are true
that's the property of and and will
force that both the conditions on the
left hand side of it and the right hand
side of it hold true and then only the
whole expression is going to hold true
even if one of the conditions evaluate
to false the whole if expression will
evaluate to false similarly for or
conditions we again write a left hand
condition and a right hand condition and
in between we write this double pipe we
can also write or or in english that
will also have the same effect and this
will evaluate in a way that this whole
expression this whole expression will
evaluate to true if even a single
condition either on left side or right
side of it becomes true so or will just
need one expression to be true to make
the whole if condition true whereas and
will force both of the conditions to be
true to make the whole expression as
true so and will require two trues to
actually become true but our condition
will require only one true to become
true so if we try to do uh understand
this logic here i am saying that if
value 1 is equal to equal to 1 which is
correct and value 2 is equal to equal to
2 then make this condition as true so
yes in this case this condition will
evaluate to true because value 1 has
value 1 1 and value 2 has value as 2 so
it will print the line 10 whereas in the
next condition i'm saying evaluate if
value 1 is equal to equal to 1 or value
2 is equal to equal to 1 so either of
the expression if becomes true
either the left side this expression or
the right side this expression either of
the expression becomes true this whole
condition will become true and line 14
will be executed line 14 will not be
executed only in a case when both of the
conditions here become false for example
if i write it like this then we know
that value 1 is not equal to 4 because
it's 1 and value 2 is not equal to 5
because it's true in that case both of
the expression will become false and
then line 14 will not be executed if i
write it like this then the left hand
expression is evaluated to true because
value 1 is 1 but the right hand
expression is false but it's fine the
line 14 will still be executed because
either of these side is true so the
whole expression becomes true similarly
here and will require both of the
expressions to be true and if either of
them becomes false the whole expression
becomes false so in the current state
line 10 will be executed but if i change
this to this then the left hand side of
this ampersand will evaluate to false
and the whole expression will evaluate
to false in that case and line 10 will
never be executed let's try to run all
of these scenarios to make a better
understanding of this so in this case
both of the conditions should work fine
so i will just right click and run as
java application and yes we see this
line 10 being printed and we also see
this line 13 being printed so both of
the lines are printed correctly both of
the conditions are evaluating to true
now let's try to play around with it let
me change this value to 4 so now value 1
this left hand side expression is false
which should make the whole expression
is false and it should not print the
line 10 which is this statement so let's
run this program and see if that works
yes we see that this particular line is
not printed now because this whole
expression became false because the left
hand side of this expression became
false similarly in the r case either of
them have to have to be true you can see
currently value 2 equal to equal to 5
condition will actually result in a
false condition because this is not a
true value 2 is actually 2 not 5 and
still we see this particular expression
because either of them have to be true
if i make both of them as not true now
both of the conditions on the left hand
side of pipe and right hand side of pipe
are false conditions what will happen
now nothing will be printed the reason
for that is that value 1 is also that
this condition is also false and value
two condition is also false so the whole
expression became false and this was
already false so this is all i wanted to
cover in this lecture we covered our
about the comparison operators and how
to use them and in the next lecture we
are going to talk about the bitwise
operators bitwise operators are very
less commonly used in the java
programming world generally we don't use
them and generally we don't need to use
them you would generally use them when
you are doing really complex bitwise
calculation where you need to manipulate
the bits now what are actually bits so
if you remember when we talked about the
integer type variables we talked about
how much memory each of the variable
type or data type was going to consume
we said that this will take one byte and
this will take two bytes etc one byte is
basically made up of eight bits and bits
are nothing but positions where either a
zero is stored or one is stored actually
the whole machine will convert your
whole program ultimately in zeros and
ones which are nothing but bits so if
you want to do the manipulation at that
level so now you can understand you are
you are actually working at right at the
machine level understanding so if you
want to manipulate the bits which are
going to be understood by the machine at
that level then you can use bitwise
operators but like i said generally we
don't need to use them now when we talk
about bitwise operators there are
multiple ways in which we can use them
we can use them with the standard and or
or operations if you remember we covered
this and or operations in the previous
lecture you see a difference here that
in case of and we are using a single
ampersand or and not double ampersand
this is one of the concept which we did
not covered in the previous lecture and
i would just like to brief you about
this concept that if you use double
ampersand that is also called a short
circuit operator and if you use a single
ampersand that is called a standard
operator to build an understanding about
this i will just quickly recap of what
we covered in the last lecture and we'll
try to explain these concepts as well so
let's go to the logical operator demo
and here if you remember there were two
ampersands and two pipes
this is also a valid expression a single
ampersand is also a valid expression the
only change is in this case
even if the left hand condition
evaluates to false
still the right hand condition will be
evaluated although we know that in case
of and either of the expression needs to
be false and the whole expression
becomes false so java provides an
advantage or with that if you use double
ampersand and if the left hand operation
becomes false
then it will not cover the right hand
operation it will not even evaluate the
right hand operation because it doesn't
matter if the left hand operation has
already returned to false or evaluated
to false then no matter whether right
side is true or false the whole
expression is still going to be false
right that's the property of and
one of these side has to be false and
the whole expression becomes false so
why why evaluate two sides why waste the
memory in evaluating the right side when
the left side has already turned as
false java takes advantage of that and
that's why if you use double ampersand
you save a bit of processing power of
your computer
by just evaluating the left hand
condition
and if the left hand condition is false
it will skip evaluating the right hand
condition and just make the whole
expression false but if you use this
a single ampersand then both side of the
expression will be evaluated
irrespective of their output so in this
case even if the left hand expression is
false it is still going to evaluate the
right side expression and similarly it
works for the or case as well in this
case in our case as we know if one of
the condition is true the whole
condition becomes true the whole
expression becomes true so if the left
hand side becomes true and if you use a
single pipe then it will still evaluate
the right height side but if you use
double pipe like this then if the left
hand side becomes true then it knows
that it does not matter if the right
hand side becomes true or false because
ultimately the whole expression is going
to be true if either of the side is true
so if the left hand side is already true
it will not evaluate the right hand side
and it will say the whole expression is
true that's why you see the single
ampersand being used for bitwise just to
explain why it why it is used and how it
is used for or operations in bitwise you
use this cap or whatever you want to
call it as and for
the inclusive bitwise or opera or
operation you're going to use a single
pipe you also use some shift operations
where you shift the value of bit of a
particular variable to either left or
right again these are again very complex
calculations if you want to use that
please read about this and use that but
in the in today's demo what we are going
to cover is the and and or examples of
bitwise operations
so here i have again created a class
called bitwise operator i have a public
static void main method i have two
variables here which are int a equal to
5 and into b equal to 7. now these five
and seven
are actually stored as bits
as zeros and ones in the computer's
memory so how they are actually stored
they are stored in a standard bit
representation which you may have uh
studied in your mathematics if to give
you a recap this 5 will basically be
written in a memory as this
0 1 0 1 and it starts from here 2 raised
to power 0 into 1 becomes 1 2 raised to
power 1 into 0 becomes 0 2 raised to
power 2
into 1 becomes 4 and 2 raised to power 3
into 0 becomes 0 so 4 0 plus 4 plus 0
plus 1 becomes 5 and that's how 5 is
displayed to you similarly for 7 2
raised to power 0 into 1 is 1 plus 2
raised to power 1 into 1 is 2 so 1 plus
2 3 plus 2 raised to power 2 into 1
which is 4 so 1 plus
2 plus 4 7 and 2 raised to power 3 into
0 is 0 so 0 plus 4 plus 2 plus 1 which
is 7 and that's how this 7 is built and
stored and now if you try to do this if
you try to write this condition you can
also write the condition into a
system.out.println block and it will
basically evaluate this condition so now
if you say a and b
in this case this is going to do a
bitwise operation because this is
bitwise operand it is going to do a
bitwise operation and what would be the
result if you do an and on this so again
use the same logic as if in case of and
if one is false then the whole
expression is false
so 0 and 0 becomes 0
1
and 1 becomes 1
0 and 1 becomes 0 because 0 means false
and 1 means true so if either of them is
false the whole evaluation becomes false
so that's why 0 or and 1 becomes 0 and 1
and 1 is always 1. the value of this is
again 5 as we already have evaluated
similarly if you do a bitwise or and if
you do this again we are doing an or
operation so 0 or 0 or basically false
or false becomes false true or
true becomes true false or true should
be true because one of them needs to be
true so this is false but this is true
so the whole value becomes true and the
finally true or true is also true so
this is the final bitwise or result and
if we convert this into an integer
representation that becomes 7 because 2
raised to power 0 into 1 is 1 2 raised
to power 1 into 1 is 2 so 2 plus 1 3
plus 2 raised to the power 2 into 1
which is 4 so 4 plus 2 plus 1 which is 7
and plus 2 raised to the power 3 into 0
which is 0 so 0 plus 4 plus 2 plus 1
becomes 7 and that's how you get
actually 7. so let's see if we get 5 or
7 in this bitwise operation yes we can
see the values as 5 and 7. so this is a
bitwise operation happening similarly
you can also use the shift operations
where in case if you're using the this
particular kind of representation or
this particular kind of representation
they are called which they are called
left shift and right shift operations so
if you use this in front of a variable
then for example this one will be
shifted here and this zero will be
shifted here and this one will be
shifted here so that's how the whole
value is going to shift all bits are
going to shift one by one towards left
similarly if you're using the right
shift then all the bits are going to be
shifted towards right by one bit that's
the whole concept of left shift and
right shift bitwise operations and if
you want to know more about this please
read some official examples from the
java doc and some other examples
available on the internet to build an
understanding on this so this is all i
wanted to cover in this lecture so in
the next session we are going to talk
about the control flow statements like
if else etc so what are control flow
statements and why do we need them
control flow statements are the ones
which can help you control and define
the flow of execution in your program
now why do we need them is because if we
want to evaluate some conditions or we
want to create some branches of
execution saying that if this condition
becomes true do this and if this
condition becomes false do that so you
can see there are two different branches
of execution of a program in this kind
of approach and that's where control
flow statements can help us there are
lot of different types of control flow
statements like if then else and switch
and for and while and do while and we
are going to cover all of them in detail
in this series so let's get started with
the first one which is the if statement
we covered briefly about this when we
talked about operators and i promised
you guys that i will be covering this in
detail and this is the session where we
will go deeper into this concept as we
have already understood that if
condition is basically used to evaluate
a condition if it is true or false the
result of an if statement will always
have only two values it can either have
a true value or it can have a false
value there is no other possibility or
there is no other value of an if
statement or of an if expression now
like i explained if you want to do a
simple programming execution where you
say if a particular condition becomes
true do this
and if this becomes false then do that
it means you need to write this else
condition as well that if this doesn't
hold true what do i do and how do i
write that so let's understand that with
the help of an example for this
particular example i've created a class
and there is a public static void main
method which is the entry point of this
program's execution i have a variable
which is called test score this is an
integer variable with the value 76 and i
have a care variable which is grade
basically what i'm doing that based on
the test score marks i'm trying to
define the grades which a student will
get so for that i have built a condition
here so you can see it starts with if
which is a keyword then you put these
standard braces or brackets and you
write your condition inside it in this
case i'm writing the condition saying
that if test score is greater than equal
to 90
then the student should get and grade a
so here i've defined this grade variable
and here i'm just assigning the value to
the grade variable at line 11 if the
test score is greater than 90 the grade
should be a but what if the score is not
90 what if this condition becomes false
and you want to do something in that
case you can write this else block here
we call this else block so you write
else as the keyword you start the curly
braces and then you define the grade if
the score is not greater than 90 what
should be the grade of the student so in
this case we are saying the grade is f
so if we try to run this example in our
inner mind we see that
the value is of the test score is 76
so 76 is not greater than equal to 90 so
this particular condition will not be
true so line 11 will not be executed but
instead
else block will be executed because if
the condition goes false then else block
should be executed as per java so this
block will be executed and grade will
get a value of f
and then we are printing this grade
value by just writing a
system.out.println
a string plus the value so let's run
this particular program and see what
happens
we get a grade equal to f here in this
cis out or system.out.println
because this condition was false so the
control the flow of the control of the
program went to line 12 and then to line
30 because this was the else block so
this is one understanding where we can
write an if and else logic you in some
cases you might not need an else block
so else block is not mandatory it's an
optional block if you want to remove
this and if you just want to do a sys
out here that is also fine cis out means
system.out.println
for shorthand we sometimes call it sis
out so you can
do something here as well if you don't
need bells block if you need this block
feel free to write it but this is an
optional block but in some cases your
conditions will be more complicated than
just a single condition if you try to
understand it from a real world example
in real world you will not have only two
grades as a and f you will have more
grades right a b c d so on so forth so
what are you going to do in that case
for that kind of case
java provides us with an keyword which
is called else if
else if is just a continuation of if
saying that okay if this condition
doesn't hold true evaluate the next one
with an else if so i've commented out
this code let me put this code back into
its place and then we will walk through
this code to understand it okay so i
have put the code back to where it
should be and this is how it looks like
so let's just walk through this the line
10 and 11 doesn't change it's still the
same but then i have added some
additional conditions saying that okay
if the score is greater than equal to 90
the grade should be a
but if the score is
not greater than 90 but
greater than equal to 80
then the grade should be b
similarly if the score is not even
greater than 80 but greater than equal
to 70 then the grade should be c
similarly if the score is nev not even
greater than equal to 70 but greater
than equal to 60 which means basically
between 60 to 70 then the grade should
be d
and if the score is even below 60 then
the grade should be f so you can see i
have basically defined the whole logic
for defining the grades here and it
always works in a top down approach one
by one the way in the sequence in which
you will define the else if block will
be the sequence in which they will be
executed so after the condition at line
10 and if this condition fails line 12
will be naturally executed if this
condition also fails line 14 will be
executed and so on so forth it will
never be the case that if this condition
fails then suddenly line 16 is executed
and then again line 12 is executed it
will always work in a line by line
fashion so make sure whenever you are
using the else if statements
write it in a sequence in which you want
the natural program to be executed so
this is all we have here and now let's
try to run this example let me just
bring the system dot out dot println
align up save this file right click run
as
java application so we see the value is
grade equal to c which means
this particular code block was actually
executed only this condition held true
now that now let's try to understand how
this happened the value was 76
so 76 greater than 90 no this condition
becomes false so line 11 is never
executed it naturally goes to line 12
because that's where we have defined the
next else if block
is 76 greater than equal to 80 no it's
not so line 12 condition also becomes
false
line 13 never gets executed and the
control shifts to line 14 and there we
have the condition saying that is 76
greater than equal to 70 yes this
condition is true so the line 15 gets
executed and once this condition gets
true
none of the further conditions will be
executed because you only need one true
statement one true execution in the
whole if else if block if that one code
block gets true that code block is
executed and then the execution jumps
out of the is if else if blocks and will
directly go to line 22 and it will
execute that had it been the case that
this particular block was also evaluated
to false it would go to line 16 and if
this was also false it would go to the
block which is else block let's see that
let's make this value as 56 so now
56 is not greater than 70 so line 15
will never be executed because this
condition will evaluate to false 56 is
greater than 60 no so this will also be
false and ultimately the grade should
fall to
else block where we are assigning the
grade as f let's see yes we get the
grade f because ultimately this block
was executed because all of the above
conditions evaluated to false so this is
all i wanted to cover in this if else if
demo there is another edition of another
way of writing if statements which we
call as nested if where we have an f
block inside an if block inside an if
block and so on so forth how do we write
that and how does the control flows in
that kind of an execution we will cover
that in the next session now in the
previous lecture we saw how we can use
an if else block and also an if else if
else block but there is another case
where we can use these if statements and
that is when you have nested if blocks
when would you use it let's take an
example let's say you have multiple
conditions to check on a particular
program and where the output of the
first condition is the input of the
second condition and the output of the
second condition is the input to the
third condition and so on so forth if
you have that kind of situation you can
write it in a nested if statement kind
of block so let's understand this with
the help of an example as you can see i
have opened an example here which is
about nested if statements i've created
a class which which is named as nested
if demo and i have created a public
static void main method inside this
particular class and now i have declared
an integer variable with the value 50
then i'm checking the first condition
saying if i equal to equal to 50 if that
condition is true then i will check the
next condition which is if i is less
than 75 and then i am adding one more
hypothetical condition saying if this is
true then also check if i is less than
55 so you can see if i equal to 50 holds
true then only this condition will be
executed similarly if i is less than 75
then only this condition will be
executed so they are dependent upon each
other this condition block is dependent
upon the previous block to be true and
this if condition block is dependent
upon this if block to be true if either
of these if blocks don't go true the
next subsequent nested if block will not
be executed so in this case i'm checking
it for first equality condition saying
if the value is equal to 50 then execute
this statement at line number 10 then
check if i is less than 75 if that is
also true execute the statement at light
number 12 and then if i is also less
than 55 then also execute line number
14. i can also add an else block as well
anywhere in this nested hierarchy if i
want to if i add an else block here that
else block will be corresponding to this
block if i add an else block here and
that else block will be corresponding to
this if block and if i add an else block
here then that else block will be
corresponding to this particular if
block so you can also use those else if
and else blocks as well with nested if
blocks and make it as complicated as you
want it to be so that's about this
program and let's see if we run this
program what output do we get and let's
interpret that output so i'll just right
click run as java program and i see some
output in the console first i get i is
50 so line number 10 gets printed
because i is 50 then i also see the next
line
output as i is smaller than 75 it means
this condition was also true because 50
is less than 75 so line 12 also got
executed and then i'm checking if i is
less than 55 so yes 50 is less than 55
so line 14 also gets executed and we get
this statement on the console so this
was a simple way to see how we can
implement the nested if conditions now
we are also going to talk about another
concept which is used in writing the if
conditional blocks which is called
ternary operators so ternary operators
are used as a shorthand of writing if
else block as you can see that these if
blocks are quite verbose we have to
write a lot of code to actually write
some conditions in this case i'm
executing three conditions but the code
is
almost seven lines or eight lines so we
will see how we can simplify this if we
use a ternary operator and for that i
have created another class which is
called ternary operator demo and this
particular class again has a public
static void main which is the entry
point of this particular program and
then i have declared couple of variables
first is int a equal to 1 and second one
is int b equal to 2. i have also
declared a result variable and we will
see how we can use this result variable
and at line 10 i have written my if else
expression so you can see this if else
expression doesn't look like the one
which we have seen before so let's
understand how do we write it if you're
trying to write an if else expression
with ternary expressions or ternary
statements then the first thing which
you need to understand is the structure
of it so here at first you will specify
the actual condition which you want to
test in your if block so this is my
condition then after that condition
you're going to put a question mark and
after the question mark you are going to
put the actual result which you want to
be executed if this condition becomes
true so if the if condition becomes true
what do you want to do whatever is that
you will write it here and then if the
condition becomes false then the logic
should go into the else block and the
else logic should come after this colon
so all you need to remember is this
question mark and this colon before the
question mark you are going to write the
condition after the question mark you
are going to write the statement which
is going to be executed if this if
condition becomes true and after the
colon you are going to write the else
block condition which is going to be
executed if this condition becomes false
another thing to notice is that ternary
operators can be used only in cases when
you have only one statement to execute
in if block and one statement to execute
in else block it cannot be more than one
statements so instead of this you can
also write
system.out.println here which will also
be fine if i just write this system dot
out dot print not print f but i want to
write println so i'll just write println
you can also do this this is also fine
you don't need to store the result
obviously
but but you can also write this
condition in a way but this all this
only has to be a single statement it
cannot be more than one statement
because this expression can only hold
one statement at a time so use it in
situations where you have to check a
condition and do something in the if
block which is only one statement and
again one statement in the else block
the same expression can also be written
in a verbose if else way in which we
have been saying it before and we'll
also
i will also show that to you and here
where this a and b is going this is
getting stored in this variable called
result so if this if condition holds
true then the result is a and this is
going to be stored here and if it is
going into the else block then b is
going to be stored in the result block
let's run this program so we can see we
get the value 1 because we have set the
condition as a less than b so yes 1 is
less than 2 so this particular statement
gets executed and this value gets stored
here in the result variable so that's
how you can use the ternary operators to
write shorthand if else statements the
same expression can also be written in a
verbose way for example you can write it
in this way saying if a is less than b
then result equal to a else result equal
to b this code has exactly the same
effect as this one line of code so you
can see this is this is pretty uh simple
to write pretty short to write the code
which i am writing here in four lines
can be written here in one line and
that's the power of ternary operators so
this is all i wanted to cover in today's
session so we talked about nested if
statements and the ternary operators
here how to use them in the next session
we are going to discuss about switch
case statements so let us first
understand why do we need switch
statements generally whenever you want
to check a condition you can use an if
else block but what if you have multiple
conditions to check what if you have so
many possible execution paths that it
becomes two verbose to write it into an
if else kind of block what if you have
to check on constant values of certain
expressions how do you do that it
becomes even more challenging and the
code becomes even more verbose so in
such cases switch statement can be used
in which you can write switch statement
to have as many possible execution paths
as you want and it will work with
constant values as well so let's
understand this with the help of an
example as how and why will we use the
switch statements so for that i have
created this class which is called
switch demo and it also has a public
static void main method which is the
entry point and in this program what i'm
doing is i'm trying to accept a number
as the month number in the program and
then with that particular number i'm
trying to print the corresponding
month's name so that's the logic pick a
month number and you should get the
month's actual name so now in this case
you can you can imagine there will be at
least 12 if else if blocks which is a
long line of if else statements at the
same time if we try to do this for other
conditions where the value is constant
please understand that the value of
month is going to be constant it's going
to be the same number so it's not
similar to you evaluating a condition
it's similar to you evaluating a
condition to a particular constant value
imagine if you have to do some sort of a
classification of employees in higher
salaries and lower salaries and there
are hundreds of salary bands in the
company so are you going to write 100
afl's logics that is going to take a
long time and then what if new bands get
new bands get introduced then it gets
even more complex so we will use switch
case statements in cases where there are
lots of if else conditions and the
expression evaluates to a constant value
remember in the if else cases the
expression evaluates to a boolean value
so here uh i'm supplying the month value
as six then i'm also creating a string
month one string variable just to print
or store the name of the month and then
the way you write the switch statement
is to write the switch keyword and then
in the brackets you supply the month
integer value and then you start writing
your conditions so you can see you write
the case as keyword and then you write
the number or the possible values this
particular variable or this particular
expression can hold so all the possible
values this particular expression can
hold will be written individually as
cases so case equal to one here one
means the value of month is one in that
case the month string which we created
here shall store january and then we see
a statement called break so break is
again a keyword in java and this keyword
has a special meaning it has a special
usage you will use the keyword break to
abruptly break the control of execution
from the current code block and the code
block is identified with curly braces so
here you can see the curly brace starts
from here and it ends
down to line number 51 at here so the
moment your java program is going to
encounter this particular statement it
is going to jump out of the current code
block execution and continue thereafter
that's the basic logic and usage of
break statement so use it whenever you
want to skip the rest of the code after
the break statement if you don't want to
execute the rest of the code you will
write break and the moment the java
program sees this particular statement
it will jump out of the current code
block specified by the curly braces and
will resume execution after the code
block so in this case it will resume the
execution after the line 51. that's the
usage and meaning of this expression
called break so in this case we are
saying that if the month value is 1
which we denoted as here case 1 then
store the value of the month string as
january and break out of this particular
code block because we don't need to
execute any further we have found a
match then another case would be if the
month value is 2 so you write case which
is a keyword and then the exact
expression value the constant value
which is 2 and if that's the case then
month string becomes february and again
you break because in this particular
case there will only be one condition
true at a time there will never be a
case that month with the value 2 will
have two meanings will have two month
names a month with the value two will
always have a meaning called february it
will never have two meanings or two
month names attached to the same integer
value and that's why you do not want to
execute any further and that's why you
write this break statement if you do not
write this bake statement it is going to
evaluate all of the cases one by one
even if the cases are not going to be
true but it is going to waste lot of
processing time evaluating all the case
conditions which you have written here
which does not make sense because we
know that only one condition at a time
can be true here because we are
evaluating and checking for a constant
value which is an integer value so
that's the reason we put a break in each
case if intentionally if you want to
check multiple cases do not put a break
statement but the program can become
really confusing in that case so take
your wise call so here we put a break in
each case similarly case 3 the month
string becomes march case 4 the month
string becomes april case 5 becomes may
case 6 becomes june case 7 we have one
string as july case 8 month string is
august case 9 we store the monstering as
september case 10 as october case 11 as
november and case 12 as december after
that you will also see an interesting
block called default this is the another
capability of switch statement that what
if none of the above conditions hold
true what if we specify a value which is
not between 1 and 12 and it will not
match any of the cases which we saw just
above and if you want to execute some
code in that case if none of the
conditions matches you may want to
execute some default execution also in
such cases you are going to use default
default is the code block which will be
executed if none of the case matches so
here you can see that if none of the
cases match then we are going to store
the value of month string variable as
invalid month and then we'll eventually
break out and once we break out of this
program we just want to print the month
string that's all we are doing in this
program that we take an integer value as
the month number and then we print the
corresponding month name here by looking
at the case blocks and we also
define our default case block if none of
the conditions hold true so let's run
this program we have specified the value
as 6 which should result in the month
name as june and yes we can see we get
june let's change the value and let's
put the value as 10 and see what do we
get so right click run as java
application and we got october yes
exactly correct let's put an invalid
value as 13 and let's see what happens
now now we get invalid month so our
default code block just got executed
because we entered a value which is not
matching any of the case conditions
which we have specified so this is how
you are going to use the switch and case
statements while writing your conditions
whenever your condition evaluates to
multiple constant values remember the
the key here is to understand if your
expression is evaluating to multiple
constant values which do not change and
in those cases using a switch case block
is a better idea than writing if else
statements so that is all what we are
going to cover in today's session and in
the next session we are going to
understand something about
two-dimensional arrays and
multi-dimensional arrays as well we have
been talking about arrays throughout
this course of java in the previous
sessions as well and we have covered
some basic understanding of how to
create arrays how to declare them how to
fill values in the array and how do we
print the array with positions as well
as the array as whole but whatever
examples which we took previously were
one-dimensional arrays because arrays
can have more than one dimensions as
well you can create a one-dimensional
array you can create a two-dimensional
array you can create even a
three-dimensional array and you can go
up to as many dimensions as you can
handle in your java program so it
depends upon the kind of complexity you
want to have in your program and the
kind of values the kind of structure you
are going to store in your arrays and
based on that need you can choose
whether you want to use a 1d array or
one dimensional array or a 2d array or a
3d array and so on in these sessions we
are going to talk about 1d arrays 2d
arrays and 3d arrays and after that
we'll leave up to you to try out more
dimensionals if you want to we have
already covered the basic array
structures which were one-dimensional
arrays so i will just give you a quick
walkthrough of how we actually handled
one-dimensional arrays so this is a
sample program to demonstrate one
dimensional arrays if you remember this
is how we use to create arrays we write
the data type of the array and then we
write the square boxes which denote that
this is an integer array data type we
assign a variable to this and then we
initialize the array with the size 4. so
new is the keyword which is used to
initialize anything in java and we are
going to use this heavily when we talk
about classes and objects and even
collections literally any object which
you want to create in java requires a
new keyword so here i'm writing new and
then int4 which means create an array of
size 4 and then i'm filling the value of
the four positions which i have created
as part of this array and if you
remember when we create these kind of
arrays we store them in a zero index
based position the first value gets
stored at zeroth index position and then
so on so forth so it will always start
from 0 and never start from 1 remember
that and after that we just print all
the values of individual positions of
the elements in the array and if i just
run this program all of the elements of
this particular array should be printed
one by one so if i just show the full
console of the output we can see that
element in index 0 was 10 element index
1 was 20 element at index 2 was 30 and
element at index 3 was 40. so this was
just a quick refresher of how
one-dimensional arrays can be written
and whenever you declare a very
simplistic array it will generally be a
one-dimensional array now let's look at
the dimensional arrays and how do we
write them when do we need them for that
i have created another example which is
says two dimensional array i just
created a class and it has a public
static void main method and i've created
a two-dimensional array this time so us
understand this two dimensional array in
a bit detail and when do we need that
generally you would need to use two
dimensional arrays whenever you are
trying to do any matrix calculations
if you if you understand what do you
mean by matrix it's basically a two by
two structure which stores the values in
the form of rows and columns so imagine
a table of two rows and two columns then
it will be a two by two matrix so if you
want to store that particular table in a
java program you would need to store
that as a matrix as a two-dimensional
matrix rows being the one-dimensional
and column being the other dimension and
that's what we are doing here and if you
want to
store that 2d matrix in a java program
the approach and the procedure for it is
pretty similar to how you create a
one-dimensional array with slight
changes
the first change is instead of a single
square bracket you are going to write
two square brackets because it is a two
dimensional array so remember the number
of square brackets you are going to put
while initializing and declaring the
array is the number of dimensions which
your array is going to have since this
is a two dimensional array example
that's why you see two brackets here if
this was a three dimensional array
example you will see three array three
square brackets here and so on so forth
so that's the first part of it second
part to understand is to how to store
the data remember i told you always
imagine the structure of rows and
columns whenever you are trying to store
a two-dimensional array in java so what
are rows and what are values and how do
you represent them while you declare and
initialize a two-dimensional array so
you start with the curly braces as a
normal 1d array but inside the curly
braces you create nested curly braces
blocks we can see three blocks here they
start with their own curly brace and end
with their own then this curly brace
starts here and ends here and then this
curly brace starts here and ends here
idea is that you provide this outer
curly braces to define the overall
structure and then inside each of the
curly braces is going to represent a row
in your two dimensional array so each of
these values these blocks is going to
represent a row so i can say that this
is the first row this is the second row
and this is the third row and if i try
to visualize it in terms of columns then
this is the first row first column first
row second column first row third column
similarly second row first column second
row second column second row third
column and third row first column third
row second column
and third row third column so individual
values are going to be represented as
columns and the whole curly braces is
going to be represented as arrays that's
the basic mental idea or mental image
you should have while declaring a two
dimensional arrays remember to declare
the rows inside the nested curly braces
and whatever elements you have will
automatically be indexed as columns
another thing to remember that since
this is an array data structure
everything starts from zero and nothing
starts from one so this will be row zero
this will be row one and this will be
row two i'm talking about the position
we can still call it as first row second
row and third row but the position of
this particular row element is zero the
position of this particular row element
is one and this particular row element
is two similarly for column as well this
is column zero column one and column 2.
similarly column 0 column 1 and column 2
and so on so forth once you understand
this data structure well and you have
defined it correctly then everything
should fall in place if you want to do a
matrix edition or if you want to do a
matrix multiplication or a dot product
all of the kind of calculations can be
performed using the 2d array concept
here in this program what i'm doing is i
am printing the values of this
particular 2d array into a matrix style
and you see some strange code here which
is for etc don't worry about this i'm
going to cover in detail what this 4
means and how do you write this for now
what we can understand that we just want
to print this you might not need to
print this in your java programs when
you write a production grid application
but you might want to do manipulations
on these
arrays as metrics maybe you want to
create a transpose of a matrix or you
want to do a dot product or addition or
subtraction or whatever be your use case
in this case just for demonstration
purpose i am printing the values as rows
and columns nothing else so this all of
this code from line 8 to line 14 or in
fact line 13 is just showing how to
print the values you can see some system
dot out and you can see some construct
here and like i said don't worry about
this i will cover this in detail let's
run this program and see if
my java array is stored correctly and
how can i represent this so you can see
i have represented it in a style of a 2d
matrix where this is the first row this
is the second row and this is the third
row similarly this is the first column
containing the value 237 so column 0
will have value 2 and column 1 will have
this value 3 and column 2 will have this
value 7 for row 0. let me also do
something here which can help you
understand this concept better let me do
a system.out.println
and let's print an individual value
because like i said the for loop can be
confusing here to understand so let's
say i want to print arr of
0th row first column and see what kind
of values do we get let me comment this
code comment is control backslash and
this code will be commented and this
code will not be executed and now only
line 15 will be executed instead of the
four block so if i run this i get the
value seven so row zero and first column
row zero first column is seven let's try
with one one i want to print the
row at zero one position remember not
the first row but the one position row
which is basically technically the
second row so second row second column
and see what kind of values value do i
get in this case i get six so second row
second column similarly if you change
this value to 2 then third row second
column which should point to 4 yes we
get 4. similarly you can write a value
here as 0 and you can write a value here
as let's say 2 this will print the
zeroth row and the second column so
similarly whatever kind of value you
want to write you or you want to access
you can access it in this fashion and
remember the column and row indexes will
always start from zero so this is a
simple demonstration of how you can use
two dimensional arrays and in this
session we also did a refresher of
one-dimensional arrays so and in the
next session we are going to be
discussing how we can define three
dimensional arrays and we'll also see an
example of it so as you can see from
this image we talked about 1d array
which is having just one axis then we
talked about 2d arrays in the last
session where we had rows and columns
basically an x axis and a y axis and
then we can also have a 3d array which
will have three axises which will have
an x-axis a y-axis and also a z-axis
think of a simple box which every box in
this world will always have at least
three dimensions and from from here you
can go even build more complex arrays
which can have four dimensions or five
dimensions or as many dimensions as you
want it to have and today we are going
to look at an example of how can we
build a 3d array and how do we access
those elements but this picture is just
to show you the mental model of when you
will be creating a 3d array so for
example generally an image data is
stored in in three dimensions so you can
you might want to store the image data
into a 3d array and there can be many
other use cases in the mathematical and
research computational use cases where
you might want to use a 3d array so but
remember there's an x axis there's a y
axis and then there is a third axis
which is called the z-axis
so let us look at a java program to
understand how we can build a
three-dimensional array and for that i
have created this class which is called
multi-dimensional array it has a entry
point method which is the public static
void main method and then i have created
an integer array and this time instead
of one or two square brackets i have
three square brackets and if you
remember i mentioned this in the
previous session as well the number of
square brackets which you're going to
put while initializing the array is the
number of dimensions of the array and
since in this particular program i'm
going to demonstrate a three dimensional
array that's why you see three square
blocks boxes let me just minimize this
yep so we have three square boxes here
and we have created the variable name as
ar
or short form as array then we start
with the outermost curly braces as is
then we put another curly braces which
starts from here and it ends here then
another set of curly brace which starts
from here and end here so this is the
this is the first dimension this is the
second dimensions and these are the
third dimensions that's how you're going
to define the different dimensions
remember this is the first dimension
when the first curly brace starts then
you have this second dimension which
covers this hole and this hole and then
you have third dimension which are these
so that's how you're going to visualize
and and put the three dimensions in use
while declaring a three dimensional
array and the values work in the same
fashion it's it's a zero index based
position so since we do not have an
official name for the third dimension so
i'm just gonna use x-axis y-axis and
z-axis to refer to the three axises so
this would be x of 0
this would be y of 0 and this would be z
of 0. similarly x of 1 y of 1 and z of 1
and so on so forth so now if i try to
access the value
which is at zeroth x position
first y position and second z position
what's the value do we get here let's
run this program and understand and
interpret the output okay
so when we ran this program we got the
output as 11. so let's understand this
output so when we say the zeroth
position on x the first position on y
and the second position on z
so this is the zeroth position on x
and this is the first position on y
and then
this element is 0 1 2 is the second
position on the z axis so to to describe
it in a nutshell this defines the x-axis
so we have two elements on the x-axis
here this one and this one then we have
two elements on the y-axis on each
x-axis so this is one this is two on the
first x-axis and this is one and this is
two on the second y second x-axis
so two x and two y and then on the z
axis i have three elements each
so hope this helps you understand and
visualize this so x-axis and this one is
other x-axis and then y-axis y-axis and
then elements inside this are z-axis
so i'm saying zero with x-axis in this
block first on the y-axis which is this
block and then second element or the z
or second position element on this
particular axis in this particular block
which is 11 and that's why we get 11. if
i print
0 let's say
i change this particular value as 1. so
now the output should be coming from
this side so
second x position because it's one
second y position so this will go here
and then the two position which is the
third element of the z axis which is 13.
so let's see if we get 13. yes we get 13
here so this is just to show you how you
can interpret this particular array and
always be mindful of how you are
structuring this array if your structure
is gone wrong then your program will
become useless and it will give you a
lot of unpredictable outputs which might
not make sense and which may introduce
errors in your program so be very
careful how you define the structure of
the elements here that's the key and
after that you just need to understand
the x-axis the y-axis and the z-axis
always remember all the accesses start
from zero so when i say two i'm
basically referring to the third element
and not the second element so this is
all i wanted to cover in this particular
session where we describe how we can use
a three-dimensional array and from here
you can go to any lens like i said you
can add more square brackets here and go
to four dimension or five dimension or
six dimension but remember the more
dimensions you add the more complexity
of the program will be having the
program will become more and more
difficult to debug and understand so
always try to take a wise call as to how
many dimensions you want to use in your
array and that's it for this particular
session in the next session we are going
to talk about the different loop
statements in java let me switch to the
java documentation and if i can find
some syntax of it as well yep so as you
can see here if i just highlight this
portion this is how you actually write a
do while statement block so you write do
you start a code block you write some
executable statements and then after the
code block ends you write a while
expression and end it with semicolon
this is the syntax basically it starts
with do or curly braces some executable
statements a while block or a while
statement basically with an expression
ending with a semicolon let's understand
this with the help of a program to
understand the structure better so for
this i have created a sample program
here which is called do while demo again
having a public static void main method
and it has a variable
which is count and it is initialized as
one then i write do i write this code
block or the curly braces and then i am
just printing the value of count then i
am incrementing the value of count and
then i am writing a condition which says
while count is less than 10 and
semicolon if you compare this with the
previous demo we ran if i just put them
side by side we had while condition
statement
and
the state change condition here we have
do statement condition change statement
and then we check the condition at the
end so the idea is that if you have a
use case
where before you even evaluate the
condition you want to print something
even before you evaluate the condition
if you want to do something in that case
you will use the do while loop even
before the while actual while loop
starts if you want to execute a
statement you will use do while loop for
example if you want to print the initial
value of the count even before the
condition checks then you can use do
while loop if that is not your use case
you can use a simple while loop which is
just described here in this program so
coming back to the do while so i say do
and then i'm saying print this
particular statement without checking
anything this condition will be executed
for the first time without any condition
check at all this will just work as is
like a normal java statement after that
i am incrementing the value of the count
and then i am checking the condition so
remember when this particular condition
is being checked the first increment has
already happened but in the while case
we did the comparison before even the
first increment the first comparison
happened with the original value of
count but here the first comparison is
happening with the incremented value of
the count hope you get the difference in
a better context now that you will use
this when you want to do some write some
initialization code before you actually
hit the condition so this condition will
be evaluated with 2 less than 10 and
then the value will be printed let's
print this example and we'll also try to
play around with this example a bit more
to bring to build our understanding
better if i run this program there is no
difference in output if you compare this
with the previous program we ran for the
while so it prints the count value so
this is coming here then it increments
the value then it checks the condition
saying is 2 less than 10 yes that holds
true if that holds true it will go back
to statement number nine again print
this
again do an increment on the count and
again check the condition with the
updated value of the count which will
say three less than ten now similarly
print the value increment check this
will continue to happen till this
particular condition becomes false and
once this condition is false it will
exit out of this whole do while loop and
it will go to the line number 12 and if
you have any statement written there you
can that statement will be executed in
this case
so let's try to change some values here
and let's see if if we can make sense of
this program if we change the value
let's say if i put 11 here what will
happen now let's run this program you
will see the
now you will see that this particular
output is displayed which says count is
11. so what happened here that count was
11 it entered the do while block it went
to this particular statement which said
count is 11 then it incremented the
value so the value became 12 and
obviously 12 is not less than 10 so it
did not print it again it only printed
once even if the first time the
condition was checked the first
condition execution itself resulted in
false
still line number nine got successfully
printed and that's the whole that's the
whole idea behind using the do while
what if i change this value to 10 let's
see what happens and after that we'll
run one more combination to just make it
more interesting this time again count
is 10 line number 10 will be printed as
count is 10 then at line number 10 the
count is incremented to 11 and 11 is not
less than 10 so in this case the loop
ends and it will move out now what
happens if i do this
if i say less than equal to here let's
run this program and interpret the
output now again only one statement is
printed because in this case the count
is 10 10 is printed here and we are
saying 10 plus 1 11 11 is still not less
than equal to 10 and that's why the loop
just exits let's make it 9 and see what
happens now you see two values so count
is 9 it enters the do while loop goes to
statement number 9 prints the current
value of count which is 9
then increments the value to 10
then at line number 11 this while
statement is executed and the condition
is checked is 10 less than equal to 10
yes 10 is not less than but 10 is equal
to 10 so this condition will hold true
it will go back here print count is 10
make count 11
again check the condition is 11 less
than equal to 10 no it's not and then
the condition will return to false and
loop will be exited so hope this will
give you a better understanding now
since we ran different permutations and
combinations of the values and we saw
when this will be executed and when this
will not be executed but the bottom line
is very straightforward that whenever
you want to write some pre-processing
logic even before checking the very
first condition of your loop then in
that case you will be using a do while
loop otherwise a normal while loop or a
for loop will absolutely work fine so
that's the takeaway i would like you to
take away from this particular session
and that's all for this particular
session we talked about do while and we
also try to give you some sort of a
comparison between while loops and
do-while loops in the next session we
are going to be discussing about for
loops in detail so first of all
understand why do we need loop
statements so generally whenever you are
dealing with some data structures in
java which can store multiple elements
for example we saw array which can store
multiple elements string is also
basically technically a character array
which is storing multiple characters so
whenever you have these kind of data
structures where you have multiple
elements being stored in the same uh
then in that case you would like to have
a way to iterate or access all of the
elements in a seamless fashion one of
the ways is to access them individually
one by one but that's too much of work
that's too much of code there has to be
a simpler way of accessing all the
elements one by one if i want to and
that's where the majority of the use
cases for using loops coming to picture
now java provides multiple constructs to
write loops in java there is a while
loop there is a do while loop there is a
for loop there is also an enhanced for
loop and in the previous versions of
java a use case of iterator was also
very popular so there are multiple ways
in which you can actually iterate over a
collection and access all the elements
of the collection one by one and you can
use it to multiple useful cases for
example if you have a huge i of employee
salary and you want to give bonus to
each of the employees and add the bonus
to the salary then you need to do this
edition for all the employees it would
be nice to have to written a while loop
and the while loop can automatically
access all the employee salary one by
one and keep adding the bonus to the
salary this would be an easier way to do
this rather than individually updating
each employee salary and the first loop
statement we are going to understand is
a while loop so the syntax of while loop
is very straightforward you write the y
keyword you enter the actual condition
which will be evaluating to a boolean
true or false so you write the
expression which will be a boolean
expression exactly similar to the
conditions which you use to write in
your if statements so you write your
condition which will evaluate to either
true or false and then you write your
statement and these statements will keep
executing till the time this particular
expression evaluates to true so
generally the way it works is that it
will enter the while block it will
evaluate the expression if the
expression becomes true then the
statements inside this particular while
block will be executed and after the
execution of the statement it will again
go back again evaluate the expression we
call them steps basically so it will go
to the next step again evaluate the
expression if this again if this still
holds true it will again go inside
execute the statement move on to the
next step it will again go to the
evaluation so this this loop will
continue to go till the time this
condition will hold true if it still
doesn't make sense for you don't worry
we will have a demo of it to make you
understand how to use the while loops
and maybe it's a good idea to switch to
the ide and look at an example of it so
i have already created while demo for it
here it is it looks very small and
simple but it will get to the point
where we can understand how and why we
will be using the while loops so i've
created a while demo class i've added a
public static void main method here
which is the entry point i have declared
a variable which is int count equal to
one so the count value is one right now
and then i'm writing a condition here
i'm saying while count is less than 10
do this so it will print the current
value of count and after that i'm using
the post increment unary operator if you
remember we covered this in the previous
sessions what is the meaning of this it
basically will increment the value of
count by one this expression is is
equivalent to if i write it in this way
if i write count equal to count plus one
this is exactly the same as this no
difference so this will have the same
impact i will just remove this line
because we already have the count plus
plus here so if we try to understand
this we are basically incrementing the
count and then checking the condition
again so at first time it will be 1 less
than 10 yes that is true it will go
inside and print the count value the
current count value which will be 1 and
then it does count plus plus so now the
count value becomes 2 it will again go
back here again check the condition
saying is 2 less than 10 yes that is
true so the while condition again
becomes true it will again go inside
this print the current value of count
which is 2 then do count plus plus so it
will again increment the value of count
so the now the count value becomes 3
again go back here at condition and
saying is 3 less than 10 yes that is
still true again come here print the 3
again go here make count as 4 4 less
than 10 prints 4 again count plus plus
count becomes 5 and so on so forth it
will keep doing that till the value
becomes 10 so at a step when count plus
plus results in the account value being
updated to 10 it will go here and say is
10 less than 10 now that is not true
because 10 is equal to 10 but 10 is not
less than 10 so this condition will
become false and it will exit of this
while loop and it will come here and it
will execute if there's if there was
anything written after the while loop
that will be executed so that's the idea
that you want to do something till a
particular condition holds true then you
can use the while loop define your
condition and execute the statements and
try to do something which changes the
state of this condition here i am
changing the count so that every time a
new evaluation happens if i comment this
this will result in an infinite loop
because 1 will always be less than 10 i
will not be incrementing the count here
and it will keep running forever it will
never stop it will just keep printing
one one one every time till your
computer program runs out of the memory
so always remember not to end up into an
infinite loop that's probably one of the
biggest mistakes any beginner programmer
does so please try to be aware of that
particular
loophole not try to run an infinite loop
always try to write something in the
code block which can change the state of
the condition and also make sure that
that state condition sometimes sometime
should become false you should also make
sure that that all that always becomes
false because if i do this if i do this
then this condition will always remain
true because it is already 1 then it
will become 0 then it will become -1
minus 2 minus 3 so and so forth but that
value of count will forever be less than
10 and again you will never be able to
exit this loop your program will be
stuck in this loop till your program
runs out of the memory so always
remember to write a statement or a
statement of execution in your in your
code block which can change the state of
the condition which results in some
eventual time when this condition
becomes false this condition has to
become false eventually otherwise you
will never come out of the loop always
remember that so if we run this program
now let's observe the output so we can
see here this particular statement is
printed for 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and that's
it after 9 the moment the count plus
plus resulted into the count value
becoming 10 it checked that condition
and then it just came out of the loop
because 10 is not less than 10 and the
condition became false so always do
something inside your code block which
results at least of one scenario where
this condition becomes false and that is
how you can use the while loop now you
can see this is a pretty generic code
and you can write any kind of condition
here write any code you want to execute
here and then do something to change the
state of the condition as well in a
positive way in a way which results this
particular condition to be false at some
point of time and then your while loop
will run fine so this is all i wanted to
cover in terms of the while loop we have
lot of more exciting stuff coming in in
terms of different loops but for this
session i think we will stop here at the
while loop understanding and in the next
session we are going to understand how a
do while loop works so i have just
opened the official java docs here so if
you see this is basically the syntax of
a for loop statement so let's understand
it and let's also try to compare it with
a while loop so that we can understand
how it compares with the while loop so
if we see the syntax we first see the
term initialization
then we see the term termination and
then we see the term called increment
now if i try to compare it with a while
loop there also you basically did these
three things you first initialized a
variable outside the while loop which is
called initialization and then you wrote
a condition
which is your termination condition you
wrote a condition saying let's say while
i is greater than 10 or while i is less
than 10. so that is the condition which
is also the termination statement the
loop will continue to execute till that
condition
evaluates to false and that's when the
loop terminates that's why we call it as
termination and then the third piece of
it is the increment the i plus plus
which we used to do in the while loops
so these three portions together
make or constitute any kind of loop in
any kind of programming language and for
loop if you see the the kind of code
which you use to write in a while loop
in multiple lines where you first
initialize a variable then you write a
condition in the while block and then
inside the while block you use to
increment the variable all of that can
be done in a single line in the for loop
and that's why i said it is the most
sophisticated and easiest way to write
loops in java so you write all of these
three things the initialization the
condition and the increment or decrement
values in a single line and then you
start with the curly braces and you
write the code which you want to keep
executing till the condition evaluates
to false that's the basic syntax of it
so let us try to understand this with
the help of an example so here i have
opened a class which is called for demo
and this is a class which will
demonstrate the usage of a for loop so
again we have a public static voidbain
method which you can see here which is
the entry point and then i use the
keyword for i put standard
braces for the brackets
and then i do the initialization so this
part is the initialization part you
initialize the variable so i just say in
try equal to 1 initialization done you
end it with a semicolon so that it is a
single statement understood by java and
then you write this condition which is
your evaluation termination condition
so this condition is basically the the
deciding factor of how long your loops
should run it's exactly similar to what
you used to write in the while block if
i just show you the example this is what
we used to do so we did the
initialization at line number seven then
we wrote this termination condition
inside the while uh syntax or the
construct and then we did the increment
here so we are doing all of these three
steps but we are doing it in a single
line so this is the condition and then
we write our increment or decrement
values which are going to change the
evaluation condition every time at every
step so we are saying i plus plus so
technically what i am saying here is
that
start with i equal to 1 and then check
the condition i less than 10 so in the
in the first step it will be checking if
1 is less than 10 if the condition holds
true go inside the for loop execute the
statement at line number 7 and then go
back to this particular statement so we
do y plus plus so i becomes 2 and then
you again go back to the condition and
again you check if 2 is less than 10 yes
it is so again you go inside inside the
for loop and do whatever is written
there there can be multiple statements
here for now i have just written one
system.out.println
so that happens and once all the
execution is finished inside the block
it will again go back to the increment
does the increment so 2 plus 1 becomes 3
again does the evaluation exec and if
the if the condition holds true it will
again go inside so this will continue
this condition checking execution and
increment will continue
till the time this condition holds true
the moment this condition becomes false
the control will come out at line number
nine so that's the basic anatomy and
control flow it's very important to
understand the control flow of a for
loop otherwise you might end up into a
program which is forever running and
which will just eat up all the memory
available in your jvm so be very sure of
what you write in your for loop be very
sure of specially
these two parts the condition and the
increment or decrement so this is very
important piece the initialization
happens only once and then this
condition evaluates if the condition
holds to true some code executes goes
back to the changing statement which can
be an increment to decrement whatever
and again compares the updated value
with the condition so this will keep
happening let's run this code to
interpret the output
so i will right click go to run as java
application
and if i
interpret the output here i can see that
it started with count is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
and 9 it stopped at 9 so what happened
there let's try to evaluate the
termination condition so let's say i has
become 9 and 9 is less than 10 so it
goes inside and it prints count is 9
which is i then it goes here and it says
9 plus 1 i plus plus means 9 plus 1 the
current value of i plus 1 it becomes 10
and then it again compares the condition
so now 10 is not less than 10 10 is
equal to 10 but it is not less than 10
so the condition becomes false and count
is 10 is never printed because this
condition has become false it will jump
out so let's say if i do this
if i put an equal to here and if i now
execute the same program
this time i will see 10 here and because
i have said that okay check the
condition if 10 is less than equal to 10
that will become true it will print
count is 10 then it will increment and
the count will become 11 the i will
become 11 and then it will check 11 is
less than equal to 10 no it is not so
condition becomes false and the control
comes out of the loop so that's how you
should always try to interpret the loops
you can also run some infinite loops for
example
if i say i equal to 1 i leave it that
and i say i minus minus so what happens
i equal to 1 1 is less than 10 yes it
goes here prints the value and then i
decrement the value i don't increment
the value i decrement the value so
whatever value comes out will always be
less than 10 and this loop will run
forever for fun let's try to run this
and i will i will have to kill this
program manually but just to show you
what happens and what you should not do
in your java program so you see it will
continuously keep printing the values
till the program runs out of memory till
it eats up all the available memory it
is cut it is forever running it will
never stop because the condition will
never remain never never evaluate to
false this condition will forever be
true so the loop will run forever so i'm
just going to kill the program but this
is something which you should avoid
whenever you are writing java code and
this happens quite often with beginner
programmers
so this is all i wanted to cover in
today's session we talked in detail
about the for loop and in the next
session we are going to talk about
another interesting way of writing for
loops which is also called enhanced for
loops we generally use the enhanced for
loops for scenarios whenever we have to
iterate over a collection of items or an
array of items those are the most
popular and common use cases of using
enhanced for loop and this for loop is
even simpler like i said it's even
simpler than
writing a classic for loop and the
syntax is
simply like this you again start with
four put the standard brackets and then
let's start from the right most because
then i will be able to explain it better
you specify the collection in the right
most side of the bracket the collection
can be an array it can be a list can be
a map so whatever different kind of
collections which are available in java
and we are going to cover collections in
detail so don't worry if you don't
understand what our lists and what are
maps and what are sets we will go into
detail of each of these one by one in
the upcoming sessions but the idea is
that you put the collection to the
rightmost then you put a colon and then
you put a representation of the member
of this collection so for example
here this numbers is basically an int
array so this int array means that this
array can only hold integer numbers and
that's why we write int here because
this array is only having integers then
we put any placeholder variable name
this can be anything you can even write
it as i if you want to you can write it
as anything any variable name which you
want to write this is a temporary
variable so now this code is going to
execute in a manner
that it is going to iterate over this
array one by one starting from the first
element going till the last element you
don't need to write any initialization
code you don't need to write any
termination condition code and you don't
need to write any increment or decrement
code also and how these threes how these
three values are actually taken care of
let's understand that as well so when we
talk about the initialization as i have
put an array here a data structure here
the automatic initialization index is
going to be the first index
so when we do the iteration when this
for loop is going to execute it is
automatically going to initialize a
temporary variable with the value at the
first index which is the index 0 as you
know that array is a 0 index based
structure then comes the condition part
so the condition evaluation is going to
be again based on the size of the array
or the size of the data structure which
you are using it is going to start from
the first index which is the index 0
and it is going to iterate till the
array's last element is reached
so technically start from the index 0
and go till the last element that's your
evaluation condition and then comes the
increment part so at each step after it
has
successfully accessed the first element
automatically the index is going to be
updated to pointing to the next element
so if it starts from here once the first
step iteration is complete i is
automatically going to be incremented to
index one and then it will basically
this i will be holding two then in the
next iteration the same i is going to be
holding 3 similarly i will keep holding
the new value of the collection item one
by one till the collection items last
element is reached so this is the basic
premise that you can write a collection
variable here and keep iterating over it
and this whatever variable you write
here will hold the current items value
one by one so in the first step this i
is going to hold one in the second step
this i is going to hold two in the third
step this i is going to hold three and
so on so forth that's the basic idea so
now let's run this program to see what
kind of output do we get so you can see
we
basically are able to print all the
elements of the array and that's
probably one of the most popular usage
as well that if you want to just print
all the elements or access all the
elements of
array or a collection one by one then
just use enhanced for loop so you can
see at each step it is printing the
value of i and the value of i is
basically the subsequent elements of the
array that's the whole idea with
enhanced for loop under the hoods if you
talk about how does it work under the
hood it is actually using the classic
for loop construct itself but for
developers it is making it easier
because it knows that if you are
iterating over a collection you will
start with the first element and you
will go till the last element so it
knows the initialization value the
termination condition and it also knows
the increment condition and that's the
reason you will use enhanced for loops
in java for iterating over collections
now there is another advanced concept in
the for loops which is around nested
loops but i think it will it will be too
much complicated if i talk about this in
this particular session itself so we are
going to restrict this session to only
discuss about enhanced for loops and in
the next session we will be talking
about the nested for loops concept and
we will be looking at an example of how
to implement nested for loops and when
do we use nested for loops so in front
of you you can see an example which i
have prepared for nested for loops and
in this particular example i have
created a two dimensional array as you
can see on the line number six i have
created an integer array and i have put
two square brackets here which are
basically symbolizing that this is a two
dimensional array so this two
dimensional array is going to hold
technically a 2d matrix and we are going
to use the concept of nested for loops
to print this 2d array in a 2d matrix
style where you will be able to see the
rows and columns clearly let's first try
to
interpret this particular 2d array so we
have a curly braces outside and then we
have these three inner elements which
symbolizes three rows basically so this
is the first row this is the second row
and this is the third row and then each
of the rows have three elements each
which symbolizes the column values or
the item values so it's basically a
three into three 2d array which has
three rows and three columns so so we
can say that this is basically a three
into three array which has three
dimensions on the row side and three
dimensions on the column side or just a
three by three matrix or 3x3 2d array so
as we know that in case of arrays
everything starts from 0 so technically
if we talk about the indexes it would be
the index 0 index 1 and index 2 on the
row side and similarly index 0 index 1
and index 2 on the column side so that's
that's something which you should
remember because we are going to use
this particular concept when we write
the for loop so let's try to write the
for loop now if you look at line number
eight we put this keyword called for and
then we write the initialization so we
say int i equal to 0 then we are writing
the termination condition and we are
saying
run this particular loop run this whole
loop which ends at line 13 till i is
less than 3 and keep incrementing i at
every step that's what i am doing in the
line number 8 then inside the for loop i
am writing another for loop which has
another different variable called j it
can be anything you can name it anything
you want and this also starts with 0 and
this also has a similar condition which
is which says run this particular loop
the line 10 basically or this loop which
is signified by this curly braces run
this particular loop till the time the
value of j is less than 3 and keep
incrementing j at every step and at line
number 10 print the element of array
which has the current value of i and the
current value of j these are basically
the positions these are not the elements
the element would be represented by this
hole but print the element which is at
current i and j's position values that's
what this code means so let's try to do
a dry run on this particular code to
understand how this is going to work so
at first we have i equal to 0 0 is less
than 3 and it goes inside it initializes
j as well with 0 and j is 0 is also less
than 3 so this condition went true
that's why we went to line number 9 and
line number 9 condition also went to
true so we went to line number 10.
remember that
in this particular case at line number
10 the values of i and j are 0 and 0
respectively and we are saying print the
array of zero and zero so zero with rows
zeroth column element should be printed
so this is the zeroth row because this
is the first uh first sub block and this
is the first element so in this case in
line number 10 2 should get printed then
it goes here and it increments the j to
1 so 0 plus 1 becomes 1 it again checks
the condition is 1 less than 3 so yes 1
is less than 3 it goes here remember it
did not go up at line number eight it
just came back from line number nine so
when it comes here i is still zero but j
has moved from zero to one so now we are
trying to access the element which is at
zeroth row first column which is going
to be
7 so 7 is going to get printed similarly
on the next iteration j is going to get
incremented from 1 to 2 and again the
condition will be evaluated so 2 is less
than 3 all good it will again come back
to line number 10 and now it will say
print the value of zero row third or the
second column or the third element so
zeroth row third element which is the 9
so 9 will get printed then again j will
be incremented and j will become 3 2
plus 1 3 and now the condition will be
evaluated is 3 less than 3 no it is not
less than 3 the condition becomes false
so it breaks out of the loop goes to
line number 12 prints an empty line
because we are not writing anything here
so it will just print a blank line and
now it will go back to line number
eight's condition and it will do an
increment of i and now i will move from
zero to one and now the evaluation will
happen is one less than three yes one is
less than three so it will again go to
line number nine again initialize j with
a fresh zero the previous j got
destroyed the moment you came out of the
loop so this is a new j so this j again
gets initialized to zero zero is less
than three it goes here remember i was
one in this time so now it will print
the value of this 2d array which is
sitting at
1 comma 0 basically second row first
element so second row first element
which is 3 again j is going to get
incremented and it will become from 0 to
1 so 1 is less than 3 yes it will again
come here and it will print the value of
the array which is sitting at array of 1
comma 1 for row equal to 1 and column
equal to 1 which will be 6. similarly j
will get incremented again again 2 is
less than 3 come back here we'll print 1
then again we'll increment j j will
become 3 3 is less than 3 no it's false
the condition is false so it jumps out
of the loop goes to line number 12
prints a blank line again goes back to
8 line number 8 increments i and i now
becomes 2 2 is less than 3 yes it will
again go here
initialize j again with 0 and again does
the same thing for the row 2 and column
0 1 2 and again it will come out of the
loop this time again when it will go
here the value will become from 2 to 3
and 3 is not less than 3 so then it will
break out of the outer loop so the idea
is execute the inner loop for every
value of the outer loop remember this
line because that is how
you will be applying your knowledge of
nested for loops to be used in certain
condition so whenever you have a
scenario where you have to iterate over
a collection based on a certain value of
another collection then you can use
nested for loops or you have a scenario
where you have to iterate over 2d or 3d
arrays for example if we were dealing
with 3d arrays then you would have seen
three nested for loops here and where it
will apply the same logic that iterate
over all the collections all the values
of the inner loop on our particular
value of the outer loop then increment
the value of the outer loop and do the
same thing again iterate over all the
values of the inner loop based on a
fixed value of the outer loop so let's
run this program and let's see what kind
of output do we get
so like i said our our motive our target
was to print this in a metric style and
you can see that it is printing in it in
a sort of a matrix representation so the
first row gets printed here then the
second row gets printed here and then
the third row gets printed here if you
try to decipher it it will work exactly
the same way as i explained so i equal
to 0
0 less than 3 condition becomes true
comes here j equal to 0 j less than 3
condition becomes true comes here prints
the array of 0 comma 0 which is 2 then
prints the array of 0 comma 1 which is 7
0 comma 2 which is 9 then j becomes 3 it
breaks out of the loop goes up here i
becomes from 0 to 1 1 is less than 3 yes
again comes here reinitializes a fresh
for loop with a new j setting to 0 and
it will it will print the array of one
zero one one one two then similarly
array of two zero two one two two so
that's basically what we are doing we
are iterating we are picking the first
row and hydrating all elements of it
pitching the second row hydrating all
elements over it and so on so forth you
can do this for any n-dimensional kind
of array or a collection so this is all
i wanted to cover in today's session
where we discussed about the nested for
loops concept and how and where we will
use it let's get started with walking
through a core java project using all
the different oops concept we have
learned so far
so in this example
we are going to have a look at a
calculator application and this
calculator application supports
primarily four different operations like
addition
subtraction
multiplication and division
so let's see how do we build that app
so in front of me right now is open the
main class
so i have a main app class here which
has a public static void main method
and the first thing we see is a read
input class which is calling a read
method
so if you go to the read input class
it has a simple static method here which
is the read method
and it is using the scanner class
if you remember i talked about the
scanner class which is used to take
inputs from the command line from the
user
so
we initialize the scanner class and we
start taking the inputs and whatever the
user inputs in terms of the expression
let's say the user entered 4 plus 5 or
whatever that whole expression
gets sent back into this
input line
as a string
and that comes back here in that input
expression
once we have captured the input
expression the next thing we do is
divide the input expression
in the numbers and the operators
basically an expression would be either
something like
4 plus 5
into 3
divided by 2 let's say let's say the
user entered this expression so this has
either numbers
or operators
so that's what we are doing here we are
using the split method of the string api
the string class basically
and this split method is going to split
the numbers and operators into two
different string arrays and here i'm
providing the split expression that's
split at every time you encounter one of
these symbols
so this when you execute this particular
statement it is going to return a
numbers array
which will be
created based on this expression so you
will get an array with 4
5 3 and 2.
and similarly in the operator array you
are going to split
or pick out the elements every time you
receive a number so this operator array
is going to hold this plus sign
this multiply sign and this divide sign
hope you get the understanding that we
are just splitting the whole expression
into two different arrays
where first array is holding only the
numbers and no mathematical expressions
and second array is just holding the
mathematical operators and no numbers
and we'll see why we need to do that in
the upcoming lines
once i've created this string array i
just want to
store or convert these string arrays
into a queue
so i convert this
array into a list by calling the array
dot as list so this expression is going
to return a list
and then i'm going to
convert this normal list
into a linked list
and then going to store this link list
into the queue of numbers
and i'm going to do exactly the same
thing for the operator array as well
converting this into a generic list
converting that generic list into a
linked list
and then storing this link list as a
queue
so i have an operators queue and i have
a numbers queue both of them have been
stored into a queue now
and then i am using the pole method
if you remember the pole method of the
queue is used when you want to fetch the
first front element the head element of
the queue so whichever element is
sitting at the head of the queue will be
taken out the moment you call the
whole method
so i fetch the first
number from the numbers q
so in this case 4 will be fetched
here
in this variable
and after that i run a loop on the
numbers q
and i'm going to run this
particular loop till this particular
queue
is not empty if you see there's a
negation here so i'm going to pick up
numbers one by one from this numbers
queue till the number q becomes empty
and inside the loop
i do the exact same poll operation for
the operations queue so this operations
queue is holding all these mathematical
operations
like plus star and divide
so i'm going to pick the head of it so
in this case plus will be picked up and
will be stored in this variable called
opr
and then i am going to run a switch case
on this opr
basically as i told you in this
particular calculator application
we are supporting four operations which
are addition
subtraction multiplication and division
so i define a case for each of the
mathematical expression
so you see there are four different
cases here
and for each case i'm initializing a
class if it's a plus sign then i'm
initializing the add class
if it's a minus sign then i'm
initializing the subtractors for
multiplication i have a class called
multiply and for division i have a class
called divide
let's have a look at what these classes
are containing
so if i go to the add class first of all
it is implementing an interface called
operate
and this operate interface has just a
single method called get results
which is accepting a variable argument
array if you remember i told you that
you can also use a
array this is called a arg expression
this means that this numbers will be an
array of arbitrary length it can be a
one element array it can be a two
element array it can be a four element
array or whatever you supply
but it is still going to be a fixed
length array but the length is going to
be dependent upon how much argument you
supply to this particular method
so that is what this interface operate
is doing it's it just has one method
declared which is called get result
which is accepting an array of numbers
so
if the add class is implementing the
operate interface then it has to
override
the get result method and here it is
just doing a summation of all the
numbers which have been supplied so if
you supply four numbers it is just going
to add up those four numbers and return
the sum
and
the exact same kind of logic or similar
logic will be seen in other operate
classes so if i go to the subtract class
it runs the exact same operation but it
subtracts the values
if i go to the multiply class
it is also implementing the operate
interface and in the get result it is
just multiplying all the values
similarly in the divide class
it is also implementing the operator
interface and it is dividing all the
numbers one by one
so it's doing pretty much the same thing
in terms of the
expression and the logic
the only difference is whether you are
using an add operation or a subtract or
multiply or a divide
so we have checked all these classes and
the operator interface as well
and let's go back to the main app now
now you also see that i've defined a
reference of operate here and each of
the switch case block
i'm assigning
the object type to this so once we have
filled that based on the case
while
filtering out this expression and
picking up plus star and divide
sequentially
then we go to the next line outside the
switch case block which is to pick the
next
number from the queue
remember we already did one poll here
so
as for this example 4 was here in this
res
and now when we do this number dot poll
again
5 will be picked up because that will be
the next head of the queue
so we pick up 5 here
and then we call operate dot get result
now this get result will be called based
on the expression which was encountered
first in the queue
again looking at the example the first
expression encountered will be plus
so the expression was plus so the
operate type object is of add type
and when you call operate dot get result
the get result method of add class is
going to get invoked
and it is going to sum 4 and 5. this res
is holding 4 right now
based on what i described here numbers
dot poll
and this num is holding the
the second operand basically
basically 5 here so 4 plus 5 gets
evaluated here in this case
and then it again goes back here and it
checks if the number q is
now empty no it is still not empty
because we still have 3 n2
left there
so
again it does the operations dot pole
and it picks up multiply sign here
then it again runs the switch case since
it's a multiply sign it will go here and
it will initialize the operate interface
reference as the object of multiply
class
then coming here it will do a numbers
dot poll
and this time the numbers dot poll is
going to pick up 3
so 3 will be picked up here
and then the current value of result
which is already 9 4 plus 5 was 9 the
current value of result will be updated
here so rest will be 9 here and num will
be 3 here and when you call operate dot
get result the multiply classes get
result will get called and it will say 9
into 3
which will become 27
it will again go back here to this
particular line and it will check again
if the numbers queue is now empty no it
is still not empty because we still have
one element left
then it pulls uh the queue of the
operations
where the expression divide is present
there which is the only element left in
this particular operations queue
and since we have the opr value as
divide
this case block gets called and the new
divide class gets initialized the divide
class basically gets initialized
and
we come here and we do numbers dot full
now the last number which is available
in this queue is 2 which gets picked up
here
and then we again call operate.getresult
this time since the operate object refer
object operate reference type was of
divide class type so when we call
operate.getresult
the divide operation or the get result
method of the divide class
basically this method will get invoked
and
it will divide the current value of
result which was
4 plus 5 9 into 3 which was 27
so it is going to divide 27
by
2 which was the last value of the
numbers dot pole it is going to execute
27 by 2 and whatever value it gets it is
going to store a value back into the
rest variable and then it is again going
to go back here
and again going to check the condition
if the numbers q is
not empty but now the numbers q is empty
because 2 was the last element so it is
going to come out of the loop and it is
going to print the final result
that is how this whole program is
working
now lets try to see this in action and
will try to execute the exact same
expression
so if i right click and go to run as and
run this as java application
and i supply an expression saying 4 plus
5
star 3
divide 2
and if i now hit enter
i get the value as 13.5 which is exactly
what we ran through because 4 plus 5
will be evaluated first which will
result into 9
then 9 into 3 will be 27 and 27 divided
by 2 will be 13.5 exactly
so this is how this whole program is
running where we first take the inputs
and then we divide the input into
numbers and operation arrays or in fact
queues
and once we have those queues built up
then we pick up the first number
and we keep running this loop till the
numbers q is not empty
inside the while loop at each step we
pick up the first expression or the
operator we check what is the operator
whether it is an addition subtraction
multiplication or division operator
and whatever kind of operator we have we
initialize the corresponding class of it
and then
we
fetch the next value in the numbers q
and then we call the get result based on
the expression
and whatever result we get from the get
result we store it back into the rest
variable so we keep updating the rest
variable at every step so that's the
reason the result of 4 plus 5 gets
stored in the rest and next time you are
calling the get result for a multiply
operation here the rest value is 9 now
and it says 9 into 3 again in the next
time the rest value will be updated to
27 because we are storing the result
back into the result variable
so this is all i want to cover in this
particular session where we looked at an
example of a calculator application
purely from the console standpoint
obviously there can be lot more stuff
which we can do into this particular
application make it more error free and
cover a lot of corner cases like
validating the inputs etc
also
looking at or putting some conditions
around the exception handling handling
the divide by zero scenario etc which is
not here but this is just to show you
the basic idea of how you can build
simple to complex cli applications using
the core java concepts
and with that we come to the end of this
full course tutorial i hope you guys
enjoyed watching the video do give it a
thumbs up comment your doubts below and
our experts will definitely answer them
for you
thank you so much for being here watch
out for more videos from us until then
keep learning and stay tuned to simply
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here